ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CALLING FOR
MEMBERS THIS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
SEVEN SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELCOME TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS BEFORE YOU MOVE FORWARD.
SPEAKER RENDON HAS APPOINTED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER TO
REPLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO TO
REPLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
FOR TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
WE HAVE EIGHT ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SP ONE FOUR NINE EIGHT
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON A
CONSECUTIVE ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED.
IN ORDER TO MOVE THROUGH OUR
AGENDA.
IN A NICE QUICK MANNER.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE WILL ALLOW
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BEYOND THESE LIMITS PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION APPOSITE
BY POSITION BREVITY IS
APPRECIATED.
WE HERE ARE BILLS IN SIGN IN
ORDER.
SINCE WE'D DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM.
WELL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
OKAY LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE FIRST
BILL TODAY IS ITEM NUMBER SIX S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY SENATOR JACKSON
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM.
HERE TO PRESENT S. B..
TWELVE SIXTY THIS IS AN ON THE
BUS FIREPREVENTION AND FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT BILL.
THAT WILL PROMOTE LONG TERM
FOREST HEALTH.
AND WILDLIFE RESILIENCY THROUGH
CALIFORNIA.
THERE WERE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
A I DON'T NEED TO TELL THE CHAIR
PROBABLY ANY MEMBER IN THIS ROOM
ABOUT WHAT A DEVASTATING FIRE
YEAR WE HAD LAST YEAR.
WITH ONE POINT TWO MILLION ACRES
OF LAND BURNED OVER NINE
THOUSAND WILD FIRES IGNITED
ACROSS THE STATE.
OVER TEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES
DESTROYED.
AND THE FIRES CONTINUE TO THIS
VERY DAY IN AT THIS VERY MOMENT
IN THE CHAIRS DISTRICT
[inaudible]
SO.
WE NEED TO GET ON IT --
THIS BILL AIMS TO DO THAT BY
BREAKING THAT CYCLE.
BY REORIENTING CALIFORNIA'S
FOREST MANAGEMENT POLICIES
TOWARD LONG TERM FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE RESILIENCY.
THIS MEASURE ENABLES FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ENGAGE IN COLLABORATIVE FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT.
AND CREATES NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LAND
MANAGERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MITIGATE WILDFIRE RISKS.
INCLUDING THROUGH THE EXPANDED
USE OF PRESCRIBED FIRES.
WE MUST MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY ON
THIS ISSUE AND I BELIEVE THIS
COMPREHENSIVE MEASURE.
DOES JUST THAT THERE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ELEMENTS THAT I JUST
LIKE TO MENTION.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CITIES AND
COUNTIES MUST ADOPT AN ORDINANCE
ESTABLISHING VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES.
WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS OF
RECEIVING MAPS OF THESE ZONES
FROM CAL FIRE.
AREAS LOCATED WITHIN THE STONES
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH SPECIFIED
FIRE PREVENTION STANDARDS
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE
MAINTAINING DEFENSIBLE SPACE FOR
DWELLINGS AND MANAGEMENT.
ONSITE FIRE FUELS.
UNLESS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MAKES A FINDING SUPPORTED BY
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT NEEDED OR
EFFECTIVE FOR FIRE PROTECTION
WITHIN THE AREA.
THIS BILL REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SEND COPIES OF
THEIR ORDINANCE TO CAL FIRE
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF ENACTMENT.
TO GIVE THE AGENCY BETTER
INFORMATION AND AWARENESS FOR ON
THE GROUND FIRE MANAGEMENT OF
RISKS AND EFFORTS AND INTENTIONS
WITHIN THOSE HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
AREAS.
EXISTING LAW ALSO REQUIRES
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO ADOPT
SAFETY ELEMENTS WITHIN THEIR
GENERAL PLAN CONTAINING AMONG
OTHER THINGS INFORMATION ABOUT
AREA FIRE HAZARDS COMPREHENSIVE
GOALS AND POLICIES.
DESIGNED TO PROTECT AGAINST
UNREASONABLE FIRE RISKS AND
FEASIBLE IMPLEMENTATION MEASURES
TO REALIZE THOSE GOALS.
ABOUT LOCAL AGENCIES MUST SUBMIT
A DRAFT OF THEIR SAFETY ELEMENT
TO THE STATE BOARD OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION AT LEAST
NINETY DAYS BEFORE ITS ADOPTION.
AND THE BOARD HAS TO REVIEW AND
COMMENT ON THE DRAFT ELEMENT
SAFETY ELEMENT WITHIN SIXTY DAYS
OF RECEIPT BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
THE BOARDS --
HAVE OFTEN FOUND THAT THE NINETY
DAY SUBMISSION REQUIREMENTS
DOESN'T ALLOW ENOUGH TIME FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES TO MEANINGFULLY
ENGAGE WITH THE BOARD.
ON RECOMMENDATIONS IT MAKES
REGARDING A DRAFT SAFETY ELEMENT.
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO NOTIFY CALIFORNIA
WHEN IT STARTS IT'S DRAFTING
PROCESS ALLOWING CAL FIRE TO
ENGAGE WITH CITIES AND COUNTIES
EARLIER IN THE PROCESS.
INSTEAD OF WAITING TO AT THE TO
THE VERY END TO PROVIDE INPUT.
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL BUT WE HAVEN'T
DONE IT IN THE PAST AND WE
BETTER DO IT NOW.
AND GET GOING NOW AS FAST AS WE
CAN REMEDIATE THIS TERRIBLE
CONDITION WE HAVEN'T FLOORS.
THANK YOU SENATOR IF YOU DON'T
MIND REVIEW A LITTLE BIT OF
HOUSEKEEPING UPSET SORT OF A
QUORUM AND WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF BUSINESS EARLIER TODAY.
THE NOT SO I CAN PLEASE ATTACK
ROLE ADWARE CURRY HERE
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE WALDRON
WALDRON HERE BLOOM.
HERE BLOOM HERE COME THE ARROW
GAVE.
REVERSE RUBIO VOEPEL YOU VOEPEL
HERE.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW OUR HEROES
WELL WHAT IF WE DON'T MIND
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECOND THERE WERE MOTION A
SECOND ON CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE STUDENT AT THE SCHOOL SORRY
CITY YOU KNOW SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY EIGHT TO BE
REFERRED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RECOMMEND CONSENT
ADWARE CURRY.
I WORK CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM [inaudible]
BLOOM I CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL AYE GALLAGHER GRIEVOUS
RUBIO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I THINK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CONTINUE WITH YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MINIATURE TREAT CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LIZ ORCED PER AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL.
TWELVE SIXTY I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR JACKSON FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY IS A
COMPREHENSIVE FIRED FORCED
HEALTH BILL THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA INCREASE FIRE
PREVENTION AND FORCE MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES TO MITIGATE WILDFIRE
RISKS IN THE WAKE OF THE WORST
FIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
THE BILL HELPS MAKE SURE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE REDUCING THEIR
WILDFIRE RISK THE BILL ENHANCES
CHO FIRES ROLE IN IDENTIFYING
ABOUT FIRE HAZARDS IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS UNDERTAKEN BY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
HELPING IMPROVE LOCALLY
DECISIONS AND WILD FIRE SAFETY.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY ALSO
INCREASES THE USE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE IN THE STATE TO HELP RETURN
LANDSCAPES OF THEIR NATURAL
BALANCE WITH FIRE ENDED HELP
ENHANCING COMMUNITY SAFETY.
THE BILL ENSURES THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICTS HAVE
THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO CONDUCT
AIR QUALITY.
PROVIDE SMOKE MONITORING AND
PROVIDE A PUBLIC WHERE HIS
CAMPAIGN ABOUT THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
WILDFIRES ARE CONTINUE TO GET
LARGER AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE IF
WE DON'T INCREASE OUR PREVENTION
EFFORTS --
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE THE
DESTRUCTION AND S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY WILL HELP THE STATE DO
THAT BY PROMOTING FORCED HEALTH
AND WILDFIRE RESILIENCY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THINK YOU'RE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE SIXTY TODAY.
MY NAME IS CRAIG THOMAS ON THE
CONSERVATION DIRECTORS HERE
FORCE LEGACY RUN EIGHTY MEMBER
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS THAT WORK ON FEDERAL AND
STATE FOREST AND FIRE POLICY.
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TODAY ABOUT
THE PLANNING GUIDELINES IN THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT COMMUNITY
SAFETY THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN THE
BILL.
WE HAVE --
THE DOCUMENT FIRE HAZARD
PLANNING A GENERAL TECHNICAL
ADVICE SERIES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
THAT LAYS OUT.
VERY SPECIFIC ON IDEAS ABOUT
LOCATION OF DEVELOPMENT ABOUT
EMERGENCY ACCESS LOCATION OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW JUST THE BEST SOLID
PLANNING IDEAS.
HELLFIRE COMES INTO THE
SITUATION COUNTY PLANNERS FIRE
DISTRICTS.
YOU NOTE THE BILL MENTIONS
LANGUAGE IN HERE ABOUT REACHING
OUT TO UNIVERSITY COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION AND THEIR EXPERTISE
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND ANYBODY
TO HELP.
WHEN WE ARE GOING --
TO PROMOTE.
A LAND USE THAT INCREASES
DEVELOPMENT AND HIGH VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS.
THAT WE MADE SOME MISTAKES IN
THE PAST THAT WAS DRIVING DOWN
TODAY ON HIGHWAY FIFTY HEARING
THE WOMEN ON MPR I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY HEARD OF IT WAS A
HEARTBREAKING STORY FROM THE
PONY FIRE THAT.
LAKE COUNTIES IN.
FIRE NUMBER THREE NOW IN THE
MATTER OF JUST A FEW YEARS AT
THAT'S AT THE LANDSCAPE SCALE.
SO I JUST WOULD OFFER THAT SOUND
PLANNING GUIDANCE.
FROM THIS DOCUMENT AND FROM THE
EXPERTISE THAT WE HAVE AT THE
TABLE MOST THE SITUATIONS INSIDE
THE SAFETY ELEMENT IN FIRE
HAZARD PLANNING.
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S THERE'S A TENDENCY
TO MAKE DECISIONS ON A VARIETY
OF EXPEDIENCY'S AND THE VALUE
LOTS AND WE ALL NEED TO THINK
THAT WE SHARE IN THIS DATA
RESPONSIBILITY. TO PLAN IN WAYS
WHERE PEOPLE FROM DAY ONE ARE AS
SAFE AS IT CAN POSSIBLY ON THE
LANDSCAPES WHERE THEY LIVE LONG.
THANK YOU SOME CENTER BEFORE WE
GO ANY FURTHER THERE WERE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT --
WERE PROPOSED IN DURING NATURIST
SOURCES WE BETTER CORRECT THEY
HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
THERE TAKE THAT THEY WERE TAKING
THEM IN THIS COMMITTEE I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM OKAY ABSENT RIGHT
OTHERS THEN --
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
NEARING AND WARMER DAM I'M
REPRESENT RURAL COUNTIES AND WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
TRANSMIT ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
JEAN HER STEERED HIM AFTER THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON EQUALLY NOT AND
IF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC AND A IN
SUPPORT ALSO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON AMENDMENTS TO INCREASE
AND NOTIFICATION WITH UTILITIES
THANK YOU.
THE SOLAR GONZALEZ POTTER HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE THE WILDLINGS
CONSERVANCY AS WELL AS CINEMA
COUNTY WATER AGENCY ON STRONG
SUPPORT AND THINGS AND IT
ATTRACTS AND KYLE JOINS US HERE
COULD CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LEARN TABLE AND SAY REPRESENT
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS.
NOT ONLY LACKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CINEMA CUNTY AG OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT FIX OUR LAND TRUST AND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I DON'T THINK I SEE ANYONE I
THOUGHT SHOES TEASING ME.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
BUT A QUESTION BUT A COMMENT OR
THANK THE AUTHOR --
A FOR WORKING ON THIS ISSUE ITOBVIOUSLY HAS ONE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT EFFECTS OF SO MANY
PARTS OF OUR STATE.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING THROUGH THE BUDGET --
AS YEARS MOVE FORWARD BUT HAVING --
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE RIGHT STRATEGIES ARE --
IS KEY THAT HOW WE END UP BY
ALLOCATING ARE.
A LIMITED BUDGET DOLLARS EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S NO WE'RE STILL
LIMITED IN WHAT WE CAN DO SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO BE
FOCUSED AND HAVE THE RIGHT
POLICIES IN PLACE THANK YOU
THINK.
THE SUMMER WALDRON.
THANK YOU --
BY TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD --
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE
FOREST YOU BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
A LOT OF HIGH RISK FIRE AREAS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
MY DISTRICT UNFORTUNATELY HAD BY
FIRE.
BUT WE ALSO EXPERIENCE THE CEDAR
AND WHICH FIRES BACK IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS IN MID --
TWO THOUSAND WE HAVE PALOMAR
MOUNTAIN TO DEAL WITH WHICH HAS
NO TREES HAVE BEEN.
DEVASTATED DUE --
TO THEY HAVE A THING CALLED THE
GOLD SPOTTED OLD FOR THAT
BASICALLY IS RESULT IN THE DEATH
OF SO MANY TREES.
AND YOU KNOW HAVING HAVING --
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS WHICH
HAVE HIGHLY SUSCEPTIBLE ISSUES
THAT COULD AFFECT PUBLIC HEALTH
OF THIS FIRE WERE.
TOO CRASS OVER INTO THEM AND
CAUSED DEVASTATION HAVING THE
ABILITY TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS TO DO THIS KIND
MANAGEMENT SO CRITICAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
HE I WE ARE OF ACCEPTING YOUR
AMENDMENTS DAM IN AND DO PASS I
JUST WANT TO SAY SHARE IS THAT
THANKS FOR BEING THIS.
FOR BUT I GETTING A LUMP IN MY
THROAT WE HAVE A FIRE RIGHT NOW
YOU IN UP BUT SO DEVASTATING AND
WHEN YOU SCHOOL THROUGH THOSE
FIRES YOU REALLY REALIZE.
DID WE HAVE GOOD POLICY IN THE
PAST.
WAS A PLANNING DONE CORRECTLY.
HOW CAN WE MAKE A WRONG OR RIGHT
OR WHATEVER?
AND HERE WE SEE IT AGAIN --
LUCKILY I GUESS WE DON'T HAVE --
THAT MANY HOMES INVOLVED IN THIS
ONE BUT I'M I DO WANT TO CORRECT
THE GENTLEMAN THE SAID THERE'S
BEEN THREE FIRES IN LAKE COUNTY
WELL IN FACT.
IN THE PAST THE THREE YEARS
YOU'VE HAD SIX FIRES ONLY COUNTY.
SO IT'S BEEN A TOUGH COUPLE
YEARS AND IT'S ONLY.
A BY GOOD LEGISLATION THAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS A HELP TO ME PER MAY
PREVENT --
SOME OF THESE FROM GOING AT
MAKING THEM ANY BETTER BAKER SO.
THANK YOU I'M I NEED A MOTION
OKAY WELL WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
YOU HAVE THE MOTION SECOND DOWN.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE UP
VERY BRIEFLY I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON FOR
POINTING OUT THAT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
CALIFORNIA'S.
I INTO IN TERMS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIAN SOUTHERN TERMS OF
OUR FORESTS A VERY DIFFERENT
FOREST SITUATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
VERSUS THE CHAPARRAL THAT --
CONTROL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIAN
CAUSES ALL THESE TERRIBLE FIRES.
CALIFORNIA WILL BE AND IS
COMMITTED TO DOING ALL OF THIS
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THIS IS
BRINGING IN OUR STATE OUR LOCAL
NOBODY KNOWS THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BETTER THEN THE
LOCALS.
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE MUST
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DEAD TREES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
JUST A NUMBER THAT'S HARD TO
CONCEIVE BUT OUR MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES HAVE NOT BEEN A
CONSISTENT AND WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE WHICH I JUST HOPE NOBODY
DENIES TODAY.
WE ARE IN A THOUGH THE STATE IS
IN A TINDERBOX SITUATION AND
WE'VE GOT TO WORK QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO AT LEAST ASSIST US
IN DOING SO THAT YOU'RE NOT
CONSTANTLY IN A FIRE SEASON.
THE FIRE AYE DEALT WITH STARTED
IN DECEMBER WAS THE LARGEST
WILDFIRE IN THE HISTORY
CALIFORNIA IT BURNED FOR FORTY
DAYS INTO MY COMMUNITY.
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THAT DOES
TO YOUR HEALTH CAN IMAGINE WHAT
IT DOES TO THE COMMUNITY.
WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE GOT TO GET
AHEAD OF THIS AND WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE PENETRATED THROUGH.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER REAVIS RUBIO
VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE.
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH MEDICARE MEMBERS
AS YOU PET IT AND GOOD LUCK UP
IN LAKE COUNTY.
OKAY NEXUS ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE WHITE HOUSE YOU.
WELCOME SENATOR.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON FED UP THE NEW I
AM HERE TO PRESENT I SP EIGHT
THREE ONE I WHICH IS MY THIRD.
PERHAPS MY FINAL BILL OF THAT
ADDRESS THE BARRIERS TO BUILDING
EXCESS THREE DWELLING.
UNITS LET ME START OFF BY MAKING
A FEW KEY CARD CLARIFICATIONS
THE FIRST BEING THAT I'VE WORKED
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
A WE'VE UP PLAN TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH ONE EIGHTY YOU BILL ARM
THAT WILL TIE HIS BILL OR
PORTIONS OF HIS BILL.
TO AND MY BILL TOGETHER WE DID
THIS A AS WITH SENATOR SKINNER
WHO HAVEN'T ANOTHER A EIGHTY YOU
PEER BILL.
OBVIOUSLY WE CANNOT DO THAT
HOWEVER WITHOUT YOUR SUPPORT ARM
SECONDLY ALTHOUGH I'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS IN OTHER COMMITTEES.
I AM WILL NOT BE TAKING
AMENDMENTS HERE A IN THIS
COMMITTEE OF ONE BECAUSE THERE
ARE.
NO AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT THAT WE WILL
PRESENTING THE BILL AS IT HAS
BEEN AMENDMENT AMENDED FROM THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
SINCE THE FIRST DAY THAT I
INTRODUCE A MY FIRST BILL ON
EIGHTY YEARS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ALONG WITH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM WHO IT IS
HAS HIS OWN OUR BATCH OF EIGHTY
YOU BILLS MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED
FROM CALLS ASKING FOR HELP ON ON
PETE FROM.
CONSTITUENTS AND PEOPLE OUTSIDE
MY DISTRICT ABOUT THEIR EIGHTY
YOU BILL.
ABOUT THE BUILDING AN EIGHTY YOU
IN SANTA BARBARA [inaudible]
A ANDREAS BLOOMS RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM HIS BANK A
REQUESTING THE FULL PAYMENT OF
HIS MORTGAGE BECAUSE HE SIGNED
AN OWNER OCCUPANCY AGREEMENT THE
CITY REQUIRED. FOR A AND EIGHTY
YOU BUILDING PERMITS THIS WAS
AFTER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AFTER TO AB OR S. B. TEN SIXTEEN
NINETEEN INTO AFFECT.
A BANK CANNOT BECOME AN OWNER
OCCUPANT IN THE EVENT OF THE
FORECLOSURE AND HIS BANK IS NOT
WILLING TO TAKE THAT RISK.
IN CONTRAST TO COUNTY JUST NEXT
TO ME GIULIANA WEINBERG TRIED TO
COMFORT THE BACK HALF OF HER
HOUSE TO NEEDY YOU FOR HER
DAUGHTER.
THE COST OF CONVERTING THE
LAUNDRY ROOM TO A KITCHEN WAS
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS THE COST
OF THE IMPACT FEE WITH TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND IN SANTA ANA JENNIFER GARCIA
REQUESTED A PERMIT TO CONVERT
HER UNDER UTILIZED GARAGE TO AN
EIGHTY YEAR.
SHE WAS TOLD SHE WOULD HAVE TO
BUILD A NEW GARAGE TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE COVERED PARKING SPACES
SHE WAS.
SHE WAS ABOUT TO LOSE THIS WAS
AFTER S. B. TEN SIXTY NINE AFTER
BECAME STATE LAW THAT CITIES
COULDN'T REQUIRED THAT.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE TOLD ME THAT
THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD OUT WITH THEIR PROJECTS
NONE OF IT IS GOING FORWARD.
WITH THESE PEOPLE ON MINE AND
HUNDREDS OF OTHERS LIKE THEM IN
MIND AYE IF WORK TO PUT TOGETHER
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY THAT WILL
HELP THESE FOLKS BUILD.
MORE HOUSING IN THEIR OWN
BACKYARD OR ON THEIR PROPERTY.
IF WE DO NOT ADDRESS THESE
BARRIERS WERE DOING TO THINKS.
WORK EITHER DISCOURAGING
HOMEOWNERS FROM ASSISTING US IN
THE HOUSING CRISIS WERE WE'RE
ENCOURAGING FOLKS TO BUILD THESE
UNITS WITHOUT A PERMIT.
A RECENT STUDY PUBLISHED BY THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE TWO DAY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ON
PERMITTED EIGHTY USE IN THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
WITH THOSE NUMBERS IN MINE.
I'VE ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
PROBABLY HALF A MILLION ON
PERMITTED UNACCOUNTED FOR EIGHTY
USE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TODAY.
THAT NUMBER WILL ONLY CONTINUE
TO GROW.
THERE HAVE BEEN THOUSANDS OF A
THE U. APPLICATIONS SINCE MY
FIRST BILL WENT INTO EFFECT.
ARM BUT WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY
OF THESE FOLKS END UP LIKE
ANDREAS GIULIANA AND JENNIFER.
I ALSO DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF
THESE FOLKS AND UP MOVING
FORWARD WITHOUT A PERMIT.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THREE ONE WILL
ADDRESS THESE REMAINING BARRIERS
ENCOURAGE HOMEOWNERS TO BUILD
THESE UNITS WITHOUT HAVING TO DO
SO.
WE'RE LUCKY TODAY MADAM CHAIR TO
HAVE WITH US CALL PETERSON WHO'S
THE AUTHOR OF A BOOK.
BACKYARD REVOLUTION THE
DEFINITIVE GUIDE TO EIGHTY YOU
DEVELOPMENT.
I BELIEVE IT'S THE ONLY BOOK IN
THE UNITED STATES AND EIGHTY
YEARS.
AS WELL AS CRAIG MISSION.
MISHIMA WHO'S WITH THE HOUSING
TRUST OF SILICON VALLEY AND WITH
THAT I WOULD URGE AYE VOTE --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRAIG
MIZUSHIMA OF THE CHIEF IMPACT
OFFICER FOR THE* HEALTH AND
TRUST SILICON VALLEY.
ON I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE IN SUPPORT OF
INCREASING DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA LEADERS HAVE ALREADY
SHOWN STRONG INTEREST IN
REMOVING BARRIERS TO EIGHTY YOU
DEVELOPMENT EVER SINCE HE
ADOPTION OF STATE BILLS INTO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND AGAIN
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL MANY CITIES HAVE
ALREADY SHOWN THEIR LEADERSHIP
IN ALLEVIATING THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
CRISIS BY INCREASED BY
ENCOURAGING THE CREATION OF A TO
USE.
WHILE SOME MUNICIPALITIES HAVE
SHOWN GREAT LEADERSHIP BY
RELAXING SOME COLD RESTRICTIONS
ON IMPACT FEES. TO ALLOW THEIR
DEVELOPMENT IT REMAINS
INCONSISTENT CONFUSING AND
LIMITED IN SCOPE.
LIMITING THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
THAT EIGHTY USE CAN HAVE BEEN
CREATING HOUSING UNITS.
THERE ARE FIFTY TWO SEPARATE
CITIES IN THE BAY AREA ALONE.
EIGHTY YOU DEVELOPMENT WILL
NEVER REALIZE OUR FULL POTENTIAL
IN ACHIEVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GOALS IF WE REQUIRE ALL.
FIFTY TWO CITIES TO BASICALLY
DEVELOPED SEPARATE STANDARDS
PARADING YOU DEVELOPMENT.
WHAT WE NEED A STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
YOU?
WHAT WE NEED TO STATEWIDE EIGHTY
YOU LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT
EIGHTY USE CAN BE APPROVED IN A
TIMELY MANNER TO ENCOURAGE THEIR
USE AND DEVELOPMENT?
WHAT WE NEED TO STATEWIDE
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE AN
AMNESTY PROGRAM TO RECOGNIZE
LEGAL NONCONFORMING UNITS SO
THEY CAN HAVE TIME TO COMPLY
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS?
AND BE RECOGNIZED SO THAT THEY
CAN NOW CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX BASE IN SUPPORT OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WE NEED STATEWIDE LEGISLATION TO
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE IMPACT FEES
RECOGNIZING THAT EIGHTY WAS HAVE
VERY LITTLE ADVERSE IMPACT ON
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHILE HAVING SIGNIFICANT
POSITIVE IMPACT TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL ECONOMIES.
WE NEED STATEWIDE EIGHTY YOU
LEGISLATION NOW TO ALLOW OUR
FAMILIES HEALTHY LIVING
ALTERNATIVES TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALTERNATIVES
FOR ADULT CHILDREN WHO MAY
OTHERWISE HAVE TO RELOCATE OUT
OF STATE.
AND FOR HOUSING OUR AGING
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS WHO
NEED INDEPENDENT HOUSING BUT
STILL RELY ON THE COAST FAMILY
SUPPORT OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
CRITICAL TO HEALTHY LIVING AND A
LONGER LIFE.
WHAT WE NEED TO STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE THANK YOU?
HELLO ADAM MY NAME IS CALL
PETERSON I'M AN EIGHTY YEAR
EXPERT ADVOCATE AN EDUCATOR
BASED IN PORTLAND OREGON AND
AUTHOR OF THIS BOOK BACK DOOR
REVOLUTION THE DEFINITIVE GUIDE
TO EAT.
PDU DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY --
EIGHTY IS THAT ONE OF THE LEAST
EXPENSIVE WAYS TO DEVELOP
HOUSING IN EXISTING CITIES IF
NOT THE LEAST EXPENSIVE WAY TO
DO SO.
EIGHTIES PROVIDED NATURALLY --
AFFORDABLE WANTED TO PERSON
SIZED HOME IN A WALKABLE LIKABLE
TRANSIT ORIENTED AREAS EIGHTY
USE ARE DISCREET.
EVEN IN RARE SITUATIONS IN WHICH
EIGHTY USE ARE LOCATED ON
ADJACENT LOTS NEIGHBORS CAN'T
EVEN TELL THEIR THEIR FROM THE
STREET.
IT IS OUR ENERGY EFFICIENT.
THEY'RE TYPICALLY BUILT THE MORE
LOCATION EFFICIENT AREAS AND
THERE ONE QUARTER TO ONE THIRD
THE SIZE OF THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
HOUSE.
SMALLER HOMES INTRINSICALLY AND
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE HEATING
AND COOLING COSTS OF RESIDENTIAL
DWELLINGS. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MANY OTHERS EIGHTY USER
THEORETICALLY IN DEAR.
BAG GOT DIDN'T SEIZE
POLICYMAKERS URBAN PLANNERS
ECONOMISTS ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND
ADVOCATES FOR ACCESSIBLE DESIGN
SENIOR HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
BUT IN FACT IT IS A COMMONLY
DISFAVORED IN PRACTICE THROUGH
MUNICIPAL ZONING CODE. FOR
EXAMPLE EIGHTY USE ARE THE ONE
AND ONLY HOUSING FORUM IN THE
UNITED STATES WHEREIN SOME
MUNICIPALITIES BURDEN HOMEOWNER
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT USE
RESTRICTION.
BY WHICH I REFERRED TO EARLIER
UNDER OCCUPANCY VEHICLE
ORDINANCES.
THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE SO
COMMONPLACE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ELSEWHERE THAT THEY NOW MAY SEEM
NORMAL BUT THEY'RE NOT.
THEY PENALIZE THE EXISTENCE OF A
LIAM LEGAL ATO AND THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FOSTERING
ADDITIONAL ON PERMITTED UNITS.
NO OTHER HOUSING TYPES MUST
CONTEND WITH A SIGNIFICANT
MUNICIPAL DE.
I RESTRICTION NOT SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES NOT DUPLEXES NOR TYPE
LEX'S NOR FOR PARKS IS NOT MULTI
FAMILY.
ALL OF WHICH ARE FORMS OF RENTAL
HOUSING IN THE SAME
MUNICIPALITIES.
BUT EIGHTY USE AND IT IS A LOAN
COMMONLY TRIGGER THIS MUNICIPAL
POISON PILL.
YOUR VOTE OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
HOUSING TYPE BENEATH SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAKE HISTORY THIS IS NOT A
SUPERLATIVE.
THE PASSAGE OF SB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE WOULD BRING ABOUT NATIONALLY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES FOR EIGHTY
YEARS IT WOULD ENABLE MORE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS BOTH
APPRAISERS AND LENDERS TO ASSIST
HOMEOWNERS TO OVERCOME THE COST
THE CONSTRUCTION OF EIGHT YEARS.
THEY MAY BE THE LEAST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING FORM OF HOUSING TO
DEVELOP BUT EVEN SO.
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING FOR
HOMEOWNERS TO COME UP WITH A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SPARE FUNDS TO BUILD.
ONE INDEED EVEN WHERE EIGHTY
REGULATIONS ARE PERFECT THE COST
OF CONSTRUCTION AND CHECK
CHALLENGES OF HOUSING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT FOR AMATEUR
HOMEOWNER DEVELOPERS.
REMAINS AS A FORMIDABLE BARRIER
TO THEIR PROLIFERATION.
THIS TESTIMONY MARKSMAN MOST
SIGNIFICANT INVOLVEMENT WITH ANY
STATE LEGISLATION TO DATE MY
PRESENCE HERE TODAY ALL THE WAY
FROM OREGON IS A TESTAMENT TO
HOW CRITICAL I BELIEVE THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL IS FOR THE
NET FOR THIS NATURALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TYPE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CORNELIUS
BURKE WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
OR THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
PROUD SUPPORT.
CLOSELY AS FOR MY VOTE GREAT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN
VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP AARP
STRONGLY SUPPORTS S. B. A THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU.
THE MAN CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE KEITH ON HERE BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA PARTLY
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT THANKS VERY MUCH.
MELCHER MEMBERS PAUL RESIST
BAPTIST HYMNS AS KOBE RETRO AS A
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO FOR OUR
AND HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ADAM RIDLEY AND YOU HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN FULL SUPPORT THANKS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW HARD
OVER THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAPTION AND STUFF YOU MORON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR ME WAS WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE AND HABITAT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MY CLAIM WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN OF HOW THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IT'S PART.
IT AFTERNOON BLACK SHEPHERD
REPRESENTING IN SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THING AND NONE OTHER NEW IN THIS
IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURRS
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REGRETTABLY IN
OPPOSITION.
I'M I THINK IN ALICE'S DOES A
GOOD JOB OUTLINING SOME OF THE
KEY CONCERNS THATWE'VE RAISED
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION BUT I
THINK AN IMPORTANT ONE IS ALL OF
THE DIFFERENCES I BELIEVE
THERE'S TEN ENUMERATED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
BETWEEN THIS BILL AND BETWEEN
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY WHICH ALSO
I'M WAS PASSED OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS YEAR.
I'M ONE OF THE KEY DIFFERENCES
THAT I THINK IS OF CONCERN TO US
IS THE FACT THAT S. B. THREE ONE
INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT SINCE
ESSENTIALLY TURNS THE EXITS WE
DRAWING UNIT.
LAW ON ITS HEAD REQUIRING
BASICALLY AN OPT OUT APPROACH IN
TERMS OF AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
SAFETY OR OTHER HAZARDS WHERE WE
DON'T WANT TO INTENSIFY
RESIDENTIAL USES.
AND THE REASON THAT'S ESPECIALLY
SIGNIFICANT IS BECAUSE THIS BILL
SAYS THAT THOSE LIMITED
RESTRICTIONS IN TERMS OF WHERE
THERE'S A HEALTH AND SAFETY AREA
FOR INSTANCE IF THERE'S A HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY AREA IF
THERE'S AN AREA THAT'S PRONE TO
LANDSLIDES.
RIGHT NOW ALL OF THOSE AREAS CAN
DO YOU BUY RIGHT CONVERSIONS
WITH IN EXISTING SPACE BUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS EXPANDS THAT
BY RIGHT PROCESS TO UP TO TWO
UNITS FOR OUTSIDE OF AND MULTI
FAMILY BUILDING.
AND FOR STANDALONE EIGHTY YOU SO
IT'S INCONSISTENT WITH A LOT OF
THE PROVISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE LOCAL ORDINANCES
THAT HAVE BEEN ADOPTED SINCE THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN LEGISLATION IS
PASSED.
I'M ANOTHER AREA OF CONTENTION
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE AUTHOR IS
ABOUT THE IMPOSITION OF LIMITS
ON PARCEL SIZE AND FOR RURAL
COUNTIES AND FOR SMALLER CITIES
AND PLACES WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
URBAN OF WATER AND SEWER SYSTEMS
BUT RATHER PEOPLE USE WELL AND
SEPTIC.
THOSE PARCEL SIZE LIMITATIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NOT A HEALTH AND SAFETY
IMPACT TO WATER SUPPLY.
AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
SCREENING CRITERIA BECAUSE
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IS IF YOU
REMOVE PARCEL SIZE LIMITATIONS
IN THOSE CONTACTS PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO COME INTO THE PERMIT
COUNTER THINKING THEY CAN GET
AND EIGHTY YOU.
THAT'S REALLY NOT GONNA BE IN
MINISTERIAL PROCESS ANYMORE
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO LOOK
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS AT THE
SEPTIC AT THE WELL AND SO YOU'RE
SETTING PEOPLE UP.
I BELIEVE FOR DISAPPOINTMENT AND
FOR A COSTLY ENDEAVOR WHEN WE
KNOW THERE'S LEGITIMATE POLICY
REASONS TO RESTRICT THE
PROLIFERATION OF SEPTIC TANKS ON
IN AREAS WHERE THERE'S A HIGH
DENSITY OF THOSE.
AND THE REASON WE KNOW THAT IS
BECAUSE IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD PASSED REGULATIONS
ON RELATING TO ON SITE WATER
TREATMENT SYSTEMS COUNTIES THAT
HAVE INCLUDED PARCEL SIZE
LIMITATIONS THE ORDINANCES.
HAVE CONSIDERED THAT REQUIREMENT
IN DEVELOPING THOSE OR THINK
IT'S AGAINST GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
TO COMPLETELY REMOVE PARCEL SIZE
LIMITATIONS.
ON WITHOUT I THINK I'LL.
BUT AT THE LEAGUE OF CITIES TALK
ABOUT THE OTHER CONCERNS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JASON
RYAN LEE CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
WE ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE.
I'M I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT EXISTING LAW IS ALREADY
VERY ROBUST WHEN IT COMES EIGHTY
USE THANKS TO SOMEWHERE BLOOM
AND CENTER WHITE HOUSE KEYS
BILLS FROM TWO YEARS AGO.
SO IT'S NOT AS IF WE DON'T HAVE
VERY RESTRICTIVE LAWS NOW ON
WHAT CITIES CANNING CAN DO WITH
REGARD TO REGULATE EIGHTY USE.
AND THEY'RE ALSO VERY INCLUSIVE
OF ALLOWING FOR NEED YOU TO BE
CONSTRUCTED THE LEGISLATURE
UMBEL IN TWO YEARS AGO I WAS
VERY MINDFUL IN AND WANTING TO
RESTRICT SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO SPUR.
EIGHTY USE WE KNOW THE LAW IS
WORKING AND IT'S WORKING VERY
WELL IN THE LAST YEAR ALONE LOS
ANGELES HAS SEEN A TWENTY FIVE
TIMES INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
EIGHTY PERMITS ISSUED.
SANFRANCISCO HAS SEEN A TWELVE
TIMES INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
EIGHTY YOU PERMITS ISSUED SO
JUST SINGING VERY SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME WE KNOW THE LAWS WORKING.
SO WE QUESTION WHY WE NEED TO
TURN THE LAW ON ITS HEAD YET
AGAIN AND HAVE OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES GO THROUGH AN ORDINANCE
PROCESS TO UPDATE THAT LAW
THAT'S JUST BEEN ON THE BOOKS
FOR TWO YEARS.
AND WE'VE SEEN LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR AND HE REALLY QUESTION WHY
WE NEED.
ANOTHER THING THAT WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THIS BILL IS
ALLOWING FOR TWO EIGHTY USED TO
BE ON A PARCEL ONE THAT CAN BE
DETACHED ONE THAT.
CAN BE ATTACHED TO THE HOME THIS
GOES BEYOND A THINK WHAT MOST
PEOPLE ENVISIONED WHEN CITIES
ARE GONNA BE RESTRICTED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO IMPOSE PARKING
REGULATIONS.
WE'RE ADDING CONSIDERABLE
DENSITY TOUR SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT ANY
ABILITY FOR US TO IMPOSE PARKING
RESTRICTIONS IF YOU'RE WITHIN A
HALF MILE.
OF A P. TRANSIT STOP OR OTHERS
TO WRITE YOUR CAR NEARBY SO WE
BELIEVE THIS MEASURE GOES WAY
BEYOND WAS ENVISIONED NOT ONLY
FOR PARKING.
BUT ALSO WE THINK OF EIGHTY USE
WE THINK OF AS GRANNY FLATS ARE
IN LAW QUARTERS ON THIS CAN BE
USED WITHOUT THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT.
AS AN INVESTOR TOOL TO COME IN
AND BUY UP UNITS HAD TO READ USE
EACH ONE AND READ THEM ALL OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL.
WE ASSUME THAT THEY'LL BE MORE
FORMAL BECAUSE THEY'RE SMALLER
BUT THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THE
ONLY WAY THE LEGISLATURE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN GUARANTEE
AFFORDABILITY IS SUPPLY DEED
RESTRICTIONS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN
TALKED ABOUT IN WITH THAT WE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE AREA
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LEARNED
ABLE ANSWER REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND OPPOSITION. TWO MEN OF OR
SOME HAVE THE URBAN KINDS OF
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN
ROEKIAH REPRESENTS CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR DAVID JONES A MATH
CITIES IN MARIN BURBANK NEAR IT
AND SAN MARCOS IN OPPOSITION.
KILOMETER THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE FOR A NOT
POSITION.
SING THEN WE WILL GO AHEAD MOVE
INTO ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
WELL SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY
HOPE WE FIND OURSELVES IN A VERY
UNUSUAL AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
A SITUATION RIGHT NOW --
YOU AND I AT AS AS YOU MENTIONED
TO WHERE THEY AUTHORS OF THE THE
TWO BILLS THAT.
GOT ALL TWO YEARS AGO WE SEE A
GREAT DEAL OF SUCCESS THEIR
ARTISTS IN THIS PICKLE.
THOUSANDS IF UNITS THAT ARE --
THAT ARE --
EITHER PERMITTED UNDER
CONSTRUCTION ALREADY BUILT NOW
AND THE OF THE LAWS BEEN A GREAT
SUCCESS AND THEN LAST YEAR
[inaudible]
WE SAW A CLEAN UP LEGISLATION
AND IN EACH OF THE A A OF THE
YEARS OR FOLLOWING EACH OF THE
OF THESE YEARS DUE TO THE
CHANGES IN THE LAW THAT WE'VE
MADE CITIES HAVE.
HAD TO UPDATE THEIR LOCAL
ORDINANCES AND AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I HAVE --
IS IS THAT SOME OF THOSE
ORDINANCES ARE JUST GOING INTO
EFFECT NOW OUR HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN
COMPLETE COMPLETELY DONE AND SO
WERE ASKING CITIES. TO DO A LOT
HERE ON THE ON ON THE SAME
[inaudible]
SUBJECT.
I I THINK THAT --
THAT THAT YOUR A BILL TRIES TO
FIX ON IMPORTANT PROBLEMS --
INCLUDING THE ISSUES RELATING TO
LOT SIZE LIKE COVERAGE FLOOR
AREA RATIO AND DEALING WITH FEES
THERE THERE ARE IN SOME PLACES --
I'VE GOTTEN THE SAME OF
COMPLAINTS I GOT A LIST FOR
WORKING ON ONE IN MY OFFICE --
TO OF OF ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
UP.
SETBACKS AND AND AND AND WHAT
HAVE YOU --
OF THE FEES A BEEN A PROBLEM --
YOU ADDRESS INCREASINGLY
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY OF A CD
WHICH I THINK IS A A IS
SOMETHING THAT'S IN IT AND
IMPORTANT [inaudible]
I AND FRANKLY SOME OF THESE
PROVISIONS ARE THE ONES THAT OF
CITIES -- A
USED TO UNDERMINE STATE AID YOU
LAWS AND THE REASON THAT WE HAD
TO BRING OUR LEGISLATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE WAS BECAUSE OF MANY
CITIES HAD.
LAWS PER THEY WERE SO
RESTRICTIVE THAT IT WAS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO BUILD
THEM -- WE
WERE AWARE OF YOUR WITNESSES
BOOK -- AND
TO WORK BY OTHER FOLKS --
TO KNEW THAT TO THE EIGHTY YOU
COULD BE A NOT THE ONLY BUT A
SIGNIFICANT SOLUTION TO OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IN SHORTAGE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND IT'S PROVEN TO HAVE BEEN AND
AN ACCURATE PREDICTION THAT
WOULD BE VERY EFFECTIVE
[inaudible]
I SO I'M AT HAVING SAID ALL OF
THAT -- AND
TO FACING A VERY UNCERTAIN
OUTCOME HERE --
I KNOW THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING HAS A BILL
I THINK SENATOR SKINNER AT ONE
POINT IN TIME HAD HAD A BILL WHY
I'M ONLY SAYING THAT BECAUSE I
KNOW SHE EXPRESSED INTEREST I
THINK THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INTEREST.
I HAVE INTERESTED IN CONTINUING --
TO TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE AS YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
IT.
OF AND I JUST WANT TO COMMIT
THAT -- TO
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE PROBABLY
THIS YEAR TO TAKE A PAUSE --
AND AND AND ALLOW CITIES TO
CATCH UP AND CATCH THEIR BREATH
IT'S NOT THAT THIS THERE ARE
THERE ARE PLACES.
WHERE THE LAW NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED THEY SHOULD BE DOING --
AND WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT --
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO LET.
ALL OF THE CITIES THAT HAVE DONE
THE RIGHT THING AND THAT ARE
MOVING FORWARD WE NEED TO ALLOW
THEM TO CATCH THEIR BREATH --
<c.green> SO THAT WE CAN --</c>
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT'S MORE A A COMPATIBLE
ANYTHING FOR ALL OF US.
YEAH WE ALSO EXPECT.
A SUMMARY RIVER FELT
[inaudible]
OKAY OPEN.
THE SUMMER WALDRON.
THANK YOU LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU
WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING
[inaudible]
I CAN.
I'M TAKING GO TAKE IT OKAY --
RICHER WHEN SHE THOUGHT I TALK
COUPLE CLARIFICATION QUESTIONS
AND THEN I'LL TO SAY WITH A MY
PIECE -- IN
THE BILL ON PAGE NINE ACTUAL
BILL LANGUAGE THAT MAYBE I'M
READING IT WRONG BUT IT
BASICALLY SAYS NO.
MINIMUM OR MAXIMIZE FOR THE
EIGHTY TWO BASED ON PERCENTAGE
OF PROPOSED EXISTING PRIMARY
DWELLING.
IT'S THEIR BE ESTABLISHED
BASICALLY CAN'T BE LESS THAN A
HUNDRED FEET IS THE WAY I'M
READING IT.
DO THE EIGHT HUNDRED FEET WOULD
BE RIGHT FOR MEN A MUSCLE.
SO WHAT WE SAW IS THAT THERE'S A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN PEOPLE HAD A
PRE EXISTING LARGE HOME AND
PEOPLE HAD A SMALL HOME SOME
PEOPLE HAVE A SEVEN THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT LOT.
AND THEY HAVE A EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY A SQUARE FOOT HOUSE THAT'S
ON THERE RIGHT NOW THAT WAS
BUILT IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE AND
THEN THE TWO LOCAL ORDINANCE
THAT LIMIT THE SIZE BASED ON THE
PRE EXISTING HOME.
YOU COULD ONLY FILL FOREIGN
TWENTY FIVE AND IF YOU HAD A SIX
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOUSE YOU
COULD BUILD THE TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT FEET.
SO.
UNDER UNDER A BIG. TEN SIXTY
NINE AND TWO TWO NINE I DID THE
ORIGINAL.
A EIGHTY YOU BILL SO THIS IS
THIS IS AIMED AT NOT HAVING.
MODEST HOMEOWNERS WHO WANTED TO
DO PUT IN A A A UNIT ON A MODEST
HOUSE WITH A MODEST SIZED PRE
EXISTING HOME THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE ADVERSELY AFFECTED VERSUS
SOMEBODY HAD A LARGE LOT.
IF IF THAT IS CLEAR WOULD IT
ALSO THEN SAY IF YOU HAVE I MEAN
SOME OF MY AREAS THE OLDER
[inaudible]
CLUB.
CONSTRUCTION WAS YOU KNOW MAYBE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT HER.
NINE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT HOME.
YOU KNOW ON A TWO ACRE LOT.
COULD THEY BUILD A THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT AID YOU.
IN NOT UNDER THIS LEGISLATION
NOT I MEAN THE THE TEN SIXTY
NINE CAPTIVE AT LEAST FOR THE
STATE AT ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THAT WAS THAT WAS THE
MAX ON YOU KNOW.
KILEY WAS WRITTEN HERE WASN'T
SURE JUST SAYS LET ME ESTABLISH.
A LOCAL AGENCY MAY ESTABLISH A
MINIMUM AND MAXIMUM.
BUT IT CAN'T BE BASED ON THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE EXISTING
DWELLING UNIT SO I WAS WONDERING
ABOUT THAT RIGHT THIS WAS THIS
WAS AN AMENDMENT THAT I TOOK
THAT WAS IN THE ORIGINAL.
NANCY SKINNER RAFEAL TING BILL
ABOUT SETTING THIS UP ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO BUY RIGHT TO GET TO
EIGHT HUNDRED FEET THE ORIGINAL
BILL SAID.
AS A MEMBER BLOOM WHEN I HAD HAD
NO MINIMUM WE DID WE SAID NO
MINIMUM BUT THEY IF YOU WERE ON
AYE USING YOUR PRE EXISTING HOME
YOU WHAT YOU COULD GET UP.
TO YOU CAN GET LARGER THAN
TWELVE MINUTES AT THIS WAS
LANGUAGE THAT I ACCEPTED AS PART
OF THAT NEGOTIATIONS IN THIS
LONG JOURNEY.
CLINTON I THAT THAT ARE IN THEIR
CITY BUT THEY WANT TO SAY THAT A
CITY COULDN'T STOP YOU OR
COULDN'T YOU HAD A WRITER FOR IT
EIGHT HUNDRED FOOT UNIT.
IN THE SHORTER SO WE HAD TO DEAL
WITH A BUILDING A GARAGE JUST
THE SAME RIGHTS AS LIMITED --
OKAY SO SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES.
HOW DOES THE WATER AND SEWER
FEES GET COVERED I MEAN?
AND BUILDING ANOTHER LIVINGS.
STRUCTURE AND SOMEHOW OR OTHER
THERE'S YOU KNOW.
THE PERMITTING FEES OR THE
HOOKUP FEES LIBERAL INVOLVED OF
WATER AND SEWER HOOKUPS.
WELL. TO YOUR FOCUS MY CITIES
HAVE THEIR OWN WATER RECLAMATION
AND TREATMENT.
SO TWO YEARS AGO I WAS BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE AND WE HAD A BILL
THE TEN SIXTY NINE GOT RID OF
ALL THE FEES.
GOT RID OF ALL THE FEES AND THE
WATER DISTRICTS CAME IN AND THEY
SAY WE DON'T GET THE MONEY UP
FRONT FROM PROP THIRTEEN WE NEED
TO HAVE SOME PEACE WE TOOK AN
AMENDMENT.
HERE THAT SAID THAT THERE WOULD
BE NO FEES BUT THE SEWER
DISTRICTS WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
PROPORTIONAL TO THE SIZE.
BECAUSE THE THEORY WAS THAT WHEN
THEY BUILT MY THREE BEDROOM TWO
BATH THEY EXPECTED MOMMY AND
DADDY AND JIMMY AND JACKIE TO
LIVE IN THE HOUSE THERE WERE
FOUR PEOPLE.
NOW YOU GO THROUGH MY
NEIGHBORHOOD IN YOU HAVE TO
PEOPLE LIVING IN A THREE BEDROOM
HOUSE SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO PUT
IN ANOTHER. SIX HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT UNIT IT'S NOT HOW THAT.
SEWER SYSTEM WAS DESIGNED BY
DOING THAT IT WAS DESIGNED.
FOR MOMMY AND DADDY ENGINE IN
JACQUI RIGHT SO SO IF YOU IF YOU
COULD SHOW THAT THAT HAD A
STRESS PROPORTIONALLY TO WHAT.
WHO WAS LIVING THERE THEN THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO AND IT WAS ON
THEM TO SHOW IT UNFORTUNATELY?
AS SOON AS THE BILL WAS SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR THE WATER
DISTRICT SAID THAT SINCE THE
BILL DIDN'T NAME THEM IN THE IN
THE DEBT IN THE LEGISLATION THAN
THEY WERE NO LONGER.
CONTROLLED BY HIGH.
S. B. TEN SIXTY NINE SO THAT'S
WHY WE HAD TO DO THE CLEANUP
LANGUAGE SO THERE WAS A HARD.
GOOD I TOOK A GOOD FAITH
AMENDMENTS. TO DEAL WITH THE
WATER DISTRICTS AND THEN THEY
SAID THAT WE DON'T APPLY SO NOW
THEY THEY AGREE THAT THEY HAVE A
PROPORTIONAL FEE SO.
THE I BELIEVE THAT THE COUNTY
THERE'S NO CONVERSION THERE'S NO
FEE FOR CONVERSION YOU KNOW.
CAN CONVERSION DISPROPORTIONAL
OR NEW THERE'S NO.
YOU KNOW FEE THAT YOU WE GET I
THINK THE QUESTION THAT THE
COUNTIES WERE SAYING ON THESE
OUTLINING.
AREAS THAT HAVE SET SIX THAT
HAVE UP PORTIONS THE BEST FOR
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION WHEN I
THOUGHT THAT THE LANGUAGE IN
THERE THAT SAYS YOU CAN.
BECAUSE OF HEALTH AND SAFETY OR
BECAUSE HE KNOW FIRE WHATEVER
CITIES TO JURISDICTIONS CAN COME
IN AND SAY THESE CAN HAVE NO BAR.
EIGHTY USE I HAVE IN FREMONT WE
HAVE A LANDSLIDE AREA THAT IS
YOU CAN SEE THE SCAR ON THE HILL
AND THEN YOU SEE THE TRACK TONES
THAT ARE RIGHT THERE.
IF THE CITY CAME IN AND SAID NOT
IN THIS AREA BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL EARTHQUAKES AND
LANDSLIDES SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE LANGUAGE WOULD
GIVE.
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO THEM IF THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION WELL
BECAUSE I HAVE A LETTER IN ALL
THOSE BONTA LETTERS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ONE SAYS --
THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF NEW
UNITS ON THE WATER AND SEWER
SYSTEM COULD CREATE FINANCIAL
STRAINS FOR SOME AGENCIES.
RESULTING IN A RATE HIKE ON
EXISTING CUSTOMERS.
WHO'VE ALREADY PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE SO BASICALLY OTHER.
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE WILL HAVE
TO SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF THE
WATER AND SEWER HOOKUPS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT DELINEATE THERE'S
ANOTHER.
NOTE I HAVE ALL THE DIFFERENT
FEES AND THINGS THAT CITIES CAN
CHARGE BUT WATER AND SEWER IS
NOT ONE OF ME I MEAN MAYBE PART
OF THAT IS THE THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ON PERMANENT UNITS THAT
ARE HAVING AN IMPACT ON THE
SYSTEM ALREADY.
THAT THE BILL HOPES TO BRING OUT --
YOU KNOW I I CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL
HOLD TIME BECAUSE I'M FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY TWO
MUNICIPALITIES THERE BUT
GENERALLY YOU KNOW WHERE WE'RE
SEEING THIS IMPACT IS IN THAT
SUBURBAN.
FOOTPRINT THE FIVE THOUSAND SIX
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT WIDE BIG
ADMITTEDLY THERE'S OTHERS
THERE'S OTHER TYPES HOUSING TYPE
BUT THIS IS WHERE.
THE THE THE ACTIVITIES GOING YOU
KNOW UTILITIES CAN STILL CHARGE
AT THE USAGE RATE YOU KNOW ONE
AND THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT A
PRESUMABLY IF YOU HAVE MORE
PEOPLE THERE IN THEIR TAKE MORE
SHOWERS AND WHATEVER.
THAT WILL DO BUT AGAIN THE
ORIGINAL TEN AND SIXTY NINE HAS
THE PROPORTIONAL FEE IN THERE
SAID THAT THE SEWER SYSTEMS IN
THE WATER SYSTEM.
ARE ABLE TO CHARGE AROUND THE
AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE
YOUR MIND VISITS THAT HOOKED UP
SOMETIMES A MYERS TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT. TO RUN
YOU KNOW A LINE YEAH AND THEN
AGAIN IT'S A PROPORTIONAL FOR
THE NEW UNITS I AND I DID A FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY FOOT ADDITION ON
TO MY HOUSE DIDN'T PAY ANYTHING
I ONE DAY PERMIT ONE IN.
IF I WANT TO BILL AND I PUT IN
ANOTHER.
CAN THAT THE SINK ANOTHER STOVE
AND A BATHROOM WHY DID THIS SORT
OF THAT IT'S STILL IN MY KITCHEN
IN MY HOUSE BUT THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE CONCEPT THAT THE
PROPORTIONALITY IS THAT WILL YOU
CHARGE ME FOR THIS.
SO JUST AND JUST [inaudible]
LAST.
POINTS ALL THROWN INTO ONE THING
LIKE IN MY AREA.
PART OF THE PROBLEM FOR AWESOME
Y. I HAVE A PROBLEM SUPPORTING
AID YOU BILLS IN GENERAL.
IS THAT.
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW VERY OLD URBAN.
AREAS SOME OF OUR PART IN MY
CITY.
A COUPLE OF THE LOWEST INCOME
CENSUS TRACKS IN THE NATION.
YOU KNOW THAT THE AVERAGE YOU
KNOW INCOME IS BETWEEN THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND ON THE HIGH UP TO
FORTY TWO THOUSAND FOR A FAMILY
OF FOUR WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS.
YOU KNOW OUR CITIES GENERALLY
HAVE OPPOSED BUILDING THE SECOND
DWELLING UNITS BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS WE ALREADY HAVE
MULTIPLE FAMILIES LIVING IN
UNITS.
THERE ONLY MADE FOR FOUR PEOPLE
UP TO TWENTY NINE PEOPLE IN ONE
HOME WITH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE DYING
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONVERTING
GARAGES AND ALL OF SO WE HAVE.
A LOT OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES CARS SPILLING OUT ONTO
THE STREETS BLOCKING OTHER
PEOPLE'S ONE OF THE MOST
FREQUENT CALLS WE GOT WHEN I WAS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL WAS THE CARS
BLOCKING PEOPLE'S DRIVEWAYS.
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
LIVING IN UNITS.
THAT WEREN'T EVEN MADE FOR THE
AMOUNT OF HILL SAYS FAMILY. FOR
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN PEOPLE ON ONE
EIGHT TEN CARS PER HOUSE SO.
YOU KNOW THE ELIMINATING THE OFF
STREET PARKING IS A HUGE ISSUE
FOR A LOT OF OUR CITIES --
DO OWNER OCCUPANCY PART WAS
SOMETHING OUR CITIES.
REALLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT WAS GRAINY OR SOMEONE IS
THERE TO ACTUALLY WATCH THIS
ACTION BEING TAKEN CARE OF TOM I
JUST GOT A CALL THIS WEEK.
THAT I HAVE TO SUBMIT TO THE
CODE ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE I DON'T
DO THAT THING ANYMORE SINCE
ONLINE ON THE COUNCIL.
ABOUT IT ONE OF THESE LITTLE
DWELLING ANSWERED BILL THAT
RIGHT UP AGAINST THE FENCE.
AND PEOPLE LIVING IN IT AND
THAT'S JUST.
AN I ON THIS AND THE OTHER PART
BECAUSE WE WANT THEM PERMITTED.
WE WANT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT TO
KNOW THAT THEIR AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO IT'S YOU KNOW.
IT'S AN ISSUE IN OUR DISTRICT
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
SOME WERE VOEPEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
MY DISTRICT [inaudible]
BORDERS.
ON NAM WALDRON IS DISTRICT.
AND WE'RE LOW BUT DIFFERENT.
MANY OF MY CITIES AND THE CITY I
WAS MAYOR OF WHEN THOUGH A
GRANNY FLAT LAW CAME OUT.
WE LOVED IT IT WAS GREAT.
WE STARTED BUILDING A LOT A
GRANNY FLATS BECAUSE IT CUT OUT
ALL THE PAPERWORK TO CUT OUT A
LOT OF STUFF IT IT REALLY WORK
WONDERFUL FOR US.
THIS BILL I STRONGLY SUPPORT FOR
THE SAME REASON --
WERE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
UNITS SHORTEN CALIFORNIA THIS
HELPS.
THE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
THE BENEFITS VETERANS SENIORS
DISABLE.
MILLENNIALS MILLENNIALS I MEAN
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE MANY.
BASEMENTS IN --
CALIFORNIA'S SO YOU CAN'T MAKE
THAT JOKE BUT DOES A LOT OF
MILLENNIALS IN THE SPARE BEDROOM
THIS GET SOME OUT OF THE HOUSE
AND GET SOME SOMEWHERE ELSE --
THERE COULD BE SUMMER
EXPLOITATION AS FAR AS THE
MARKET GOES.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT.
YOU'RE ABLE TO BUILD A GRANNY
FLAT AND RENTED OUT TO SOMEONE
ELSE NOT YOUR GRANNY OKAY WITH
ME [inaudible]
IT'S GREATLY --
PRODUCING HOUSING SO SENATOR I
THINK THIS IS SPOT ON I SUPPORT
IT AND I HOPE MY COLLEAGUES WILL
SUPPORT IT [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THAT SEE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SO -- I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION
FOR THIS.
AND I UNDERSTAND --
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GET --
TO BUT THIS COMMITTEE ALREADY
PASSED IN APRIL THIS YEAR --
A BILL AB YOU LOST IT FOR A YEAR
LAW AB TWENTY EIGHT NINE
DIFFERENT TING AND WE WORKED
REALLY HARD. TO GET THAT BILL
OUT HERE AND WE THINK IT DID THE
RIGHT THING --
MISTER TING SO MEMBER TING
NARROW THE SCOPE OF HIS BILL AT
THE REQUEST OF THE COMMITTEE
INCLUDING REVERTING THE FEE
PROVISIONS BACK TO EXISTING LAW.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS I
ASKED HIM TO TAKE AS COMMON GUT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
GIVEN THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
ALREADY READ IT THAT THE POLICY
IN AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TING
AND MANY CONFLICTS THAT YOUR
BILL HAS WITH AB.
TWENTY NINETY I'M NOT ENOUGH
SUPPORT TO BUILD A DAY --
IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MOTION
[inaudible]
SO MOVED.
MOVED A BILL
.
SO WE DON'T HAVE A SECOND SO DO
THE LACK OF A MOTION THIS BILL
WILL BE HELD IN COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I NEXT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SP TEN EIGHTEEN ROOSTER ALAN.
SOME A SENATOR ALAN
[inaudible]
YEAH
VOTE.
SO MISTER ALLEN HERE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AND IT --
WE'RE READY TO GO APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE MEMBERS AND I YOU
KNOW I I I'M MYSELF CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE IN THE HOUSE.
SO WHERE.
A PROCEDURE PATIENTS SO THIS
BILL S. B. TEN EIGHTEEN BUILDS
UPON PASS LEGISLATION BY GIVING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMMUNICATIVE.
SIX AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS THE
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH
INDEPENDENT HYBRID OR ADVISORY
COMMISSIONS.
AND THEN MAKE VERY AND THAT ALSO
MAKES VERY SOON TO STREAMLINING
CLARIFY THE LAW.
ALLOWING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
CREATE THIRD WE DISTURBING
COMMISSIONS.
THE BEGINNING WITH THE APPROVAL
OF PROPOSITION.
ELEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WHICH CREATED THE CITIZENS WERE
DIFFERENT COMMISSIONS THAT ONE
KNOWS ABOUT.
AYE INDEPENDENT REISSUE
COMMISSIONS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
STIR CLIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NOW ARE SEAT ASSEMBLY OUR
STATE SENATE.
OR BOARD OF EQUALIZATION OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS ARE ALL
DRAWN.
BY THESE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS.
NOW DRIVEN BY YOU KNOW A LOT OF
INTEREST IN NON PARTISAN
REDISTRICTING AYE.
AUTHORED S. B. ELEVEN AWAY IT
BACK TO TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
AUTHORIZES ALL COUNTIES AND
CITIES. TO ESTABLISH THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENT OR ADVISORY RESTRICT
COMMISSIONS ARE NOW THIRTEEN
DIFFERENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
THE UC DIEGO IT MODESTO OAKLAND
SACRAMENTO THEY'VE ALL NOW
ESTABLISH INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS.
SO THIS BILL BUILT UPON THAT
PASSED LEGISLATION BY NOW GIVING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMMUNICATIVE
SYSTRACE.
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THIS AUTHORITY
TO ESTABLISH THESE INDEPENDENT.
A HYBRID OR ADVISORY COMMISSIONS
IT'LL BRING MORE TRANSPARENT IN
NON PARTISAN REDISTRICTING TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE BUT IMPORTANTLY THE
BILL PROVIDES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
WITH THE CHOICE. TO UTILIZE
INDEPENDENT HYBRID OR ADVISORY
PRESERVING COMMISSIONS DOESN'T
MANDATE THAT IF THEY DO SO ON
THE BILL ALSO CLARIFIES IT
STREAMLINES CURRENT LAW.
TO ENSURE A SMOOTH PROCESS FOR
REDISTRICTING AFTER THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS.
AND SOME OF THOSE CHANGES
INVOLVED ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNMENT'S A CONTRACT WITH
THAT COUNTIES INDEPENDENT
REDUCING COMMISSION BUT
REQUIRING THE COMMISSION TO HOLD
AT LEAST THREE PUBLIC HEARINGS.
IN THE LOCAL JURISDICTION BEFORE
ADOPTING THE BOUNDARIES
PROHIBITING DISTRICT BOUNDARIES
THAT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST A
POLITICAL PARTY PROHIBITING
LEGISLATIVE BOUNDARIES FROM
REPEALING DISTRICT BOUNDARIES
THAT HAVE BEEN DRAWN.
BY ONE OF THE COMMISSIONS ARE
AND THEN ALSO REDUCING BY OR
INDEPENDENT HYPER COMMISSION AND
THE REDUCING SOME QUALIFICATIONS
AND POST SERVICE REQUIREMENTS.
I TO ALLOW MORE CITIZENS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS WE
GOT A GREAT LIST OF SUPPORTERS
OUT HERE WE HAVE TODAY AND SPEAK
IN SUPPORT NICHOLS HIGH DURING
HIS.
REPRESENTING COMMON CAUSE OR
ROSE IS ALSO PRESENTING WHAT
[inaudible]
BUT XANDER NOT DOOR ROSE OKAY --
REPRESENT LEAGUE WOMEN VOTERS IN
THAT RESPECT YES RIGHT VOTE.
GREAT LET'S HEAR FROM ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLAS
I DON'T WITH CALIFORNIA COME
BECAUSE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
COME BECAUSE FIRMLY SPORTS USE
OF INDEPENDENT COMMISSION REDUCE
TING INCLUDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
STUDIES OF INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS LIKE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMISSION FINALLY TYPICALLY DO
A BETTER JOB THAN LET'S OF
BODIES DURING DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES LONG A NUMBER OF
METRICS INCLUDING KEEPING CITIES
COMMUNITIES NEVER TOLL PROMOTING
PARTISAN FAIRNESS.
THOSE INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MINORITY REPRESENTATION.
AS OTHER MENTIONING CALIFORNIA
SINCE CHRISTMAS DAY COMMISSION
WE'VE SEEN A SURGE OF INTEREST
AND LOCAL CONNECTIONS AT THE
LOCAL.
THERE FOURTEEN JURISDICTIONS
DAVID NOW HAVE INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS RECOGNITION THIS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED S. B. ELEVEN WAY TO ALLOW
COUNTIES IN GENERAL US AT LEAST
CREE COMMISSIONS.
THIS BILL DOES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT THINGS BUILDING OFF OF
THAT AUTHORITY THAT
LEGISLATURE'S RT STYLISH.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY NOW ALLOWS
ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT WISHES
TO ESTABLISH COMMISSION THE
AUTHORITY TO DO SO.
IF REDUCING IS A BEST PRACTICE
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES WE SEE
NO REASON WHY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS SHOULD
ALSO HAVE THAT OPTION.
TO CREATE COMMISSION'S IF THEY
WISH.
TO BILLS TO FINE TUNE SOME THE
REQUIREMENTS ON LOCAL
COMMISSIONS ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT REQUIREMENTS IS TO
PROHIBIT ANY DISCRIMINATION ON
THE BASIS OF POLITICAL PARTIES
SHOULD SOMEONE GO AHEAD AND
CREATE.
AN INDEPENDENT COMMISSION.
FINALLY THE BILL ALSO RELAXES
SOME OF THE COMMISSIONER OLD
ABILITY OF SERVICE REQUIREMENTS
THIS IS REALLY RECOGNITION.
SMALLER JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
A SMALLER POOL OF POTENTIAL
HOPKINS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
ALL JURISDICTION WILL ADOPT
THESE COMMISSIONS.
FINALLY THE BILL JUST THREE
WORDS SOME PROVISIONS TO MAKE
EXISTING LAW CLEAR FOR EXAMPLE
TO SPECIFY THAT ALTHOUGH THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION TALKS Y.
RESISTING.
COMMISSIONS CAN ALSO BE CREATED
IN THE DISTRICTING CONTACTS
WHICH SWING DISTRICT LINES ARE
BEING SELFISH FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SO CONCLUDE CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
LEADER ON STATE AND FEDERAL
REDISTRICTING AND WITH THIS BILL
WE THINK WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
LEADER ON LOCAL REDUCING WE
STRONGLY OR SPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M ANDREAS FISCHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS THAT
CALIFORNIA FILLING IN FOR DOOR
ROSE I'M ANYTHING GIVEN
OPPORTUNITIES --
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ITS S. B..
TEN EIGHTEEN SO WE AT THE LEAGUE --
SUPPORT REDISTRICTING --
PROCESS THAT IS STRUCTURED TO
PROMOTE FAIR AND EFFECTIVE
REPRESENTS REPRESENTATION --
AND THAT ALLOWS FOR A HIGH
DEGREE OF PUBLIC.
ABILITY FOR REDISTRICTING SHOULD
BE VESTED IN AN INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION WITH DIVERSE
MEMBERSHIP.
THAT IS A COMMISSION THAT WILL
EFFECTIVELY REPRESENT THE PUBLIC
OVERALL WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
PROTECTING THE INTERESTS OF
MINORITY GROUPS.
WE REJECT SYSTEMS THAT PROTECT
INCUMBENTS AND ONES THAT PROVIDE
PREFER --
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT FOR ANY
POLITICAL PARTY [inaudible]
I AND WE BELIEVE MAINTAIN THAT
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN THIS
PROCESS IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE.
I S. B. TEN EIGHTEEN PROVIDES
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS RELATED
TO THE ORIGINAL AND TEN UP S. B.
AT ELEVEN OO.
EIGHT AS YOU'VE HEARD IT WOULD
CLARIFY BOTH AT THE LA TIMES TO
INITIAL DISTRICTING AND THAT --
HYBRID COMMISSIONS I HAVE TO
MEET THE SAME STANDARDS OF
INDEPENDENCE AND TRANSPARENCY.
AS INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS.
ON THIS BILL --
WOULD REMOVE BARRIERS THAT
COMPLICATE THE CREATION OFLOCAL
NONPARTISAN COMMISSIONS --
AT AT THE SAME TIME IT BROADENS
THE JURISDICTION JURISDICTIONS
THAT MAY ESTABLISH INDEPENDENCE --
COMMISSIONS BEYOND COUNTIES AND
CITIES.
S. B. TEN AT TEN EIGHTEEN WILL
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO FAIR AND
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY.
AND IT --
DEMONSTRATES HER RESOLVE TO GIVE
THE PEOPLE I THE POWER TO CHOOSE
THEIR POLITICIANS.
I FOR THESE REASONS THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS S. B. TEN EIGHTEEN AND
STRONGLY ENCOURAGES.
A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
AND THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
APPEARS THAT THERE ARE NONE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
AND A QUESTION.
WITH WALDRON SOME TRYING I WANT
TO BE SUPPORTIVE SO MY QUESTION
IS -- SO A
LOT OF THESE LOCAL.
ARE THESE OFFICES ARE
NONPARTISAN TO BEGIN.
RIGHT SO THE ENTITY WOULD CHOOSE
ITS OWN PEOPLE SAY OF CITY
COUNCIL.
WOULD DO SOME TYPE OF PROCESS BY
WHICH THEY APPOINT MEMBERS TO BE
ON THE COMMISSION.
AND THEN THEY ACT INDEPENDENTLY
THE GOAL IS THERE INDEPENDENT --
SOLD GENERALLY JUST NATURALLY I
WOULD ASSUME IF YOU HAVE THE
CITY COUNCIL THAT HAS SAY FOR
MEMBERS OF ONE PARTY IN. ONE OF
ANOTHER THEY WOULD CREATIVE
COMMISSION THAT.
WOULD REPRESENT THAT OR IF IT
WAS THE OFFICES YOU KNOW MAYBE
TO TO IN TO AN INDEPENDENT OR SO
THAT.
THEY GENERALLY END UP REFLECTING
THE EXISTING ELECTED BODY.
I MEAN TO SAT TO MAKE SENSE WHEN
I'M SAYING.
SHARIA.
IT THE WAY THE LAW IS STRUCTURED --
IT IS DESIGNED TO GIVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SOME FLEXIBILITY
IN HOW COMMISSIONERS ARE
APPOINTED THIS IS IN RECOGNITION
OF THE DIVERSITY THAT ALREADY
EXISTS WITHIN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE.
A SOME COMMUNITIES LIKE HAVING A
PANEL OF RETIRED JUDGES DRIVE
LINES OTHERS LIKE USING A RANDOM
SELECTION PROCESS.
BUT IT DOES HAVE IS MULTIPLE
PROTECTIONS TRYING TO AVOID ANY
AFFECTING THE PROCESS IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE NON PARTISAN RACES.
SERVER EXAMPLE QUALIFICATIONS
ARE EXTREMELY.
PAYNE DONORS CAN'T BE ON THE
COMMISSION PEOPLE HER PARTY
OFFICIALS CAN'T BE ON THE
COMMISSION PEOPLE OFTEN CAN
THAT'S FOR OFFICE CAN'T BE ON
THE COMMISSION.
SO THERE'S A COLD CASE MOMENTS
TRAIN SCREEN THAT OUT IT HAS TO
BE AN OPEN AYE APPLICATION
PROCESS.
AND FINALLY NO DIRECT
APPOINTMENT TO THE COMMISSION
HAS PROVIDED SO.
IS ALLOWED SO WHATEVER METHOD IS
ULTIMATELY SELECTED TO APPOINT
COMMISSIONERS THE HOPE IS THAT
THROUGH ALL THESE PROTECTIONS WE
PUT AND YOU'RE TRULY CAN HAVE
PEOPLE WERE.
PRETTY NONPARTISAN NOT COMING IN
WITH AN AXE TO GRIND FOR TRYING
TO BEST REPRESENT COMMUNITIES
LETTER.
AND IT SOUNDS BETTER I MEAN THEN
WHAT.
EXISTS NOW IT'S AN IMPROVEMENT I
MEAN THAT'S WHEN --
ALSO IT MIGHT HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THE VOTER RIGHT AT VOTER
RIGHTS ACT LAWSUITS.
WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW IN THE PAST
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT SOMEONE SO
WILL DO YOU KNOW THE OUTCOME OF
THE ELECTION.
BASED ON THIS COMMITTEE WHO DREW
THE LINES IN THE ON THE COULD GO
BACK TO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO HAVING THOSE PROTECTIONS IS
HELPFUL.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WERE LOOKING
FOR A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION IN A SECOND AND
TO WITH THE AUTHOR LIKE CLOSER
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
I KNOW COMMON CAUSES IS
INCREDIBLY COMMITTED TO GOOD
GOVERNMENT BIPARTISAN
[inaudible]
NONPARTISAN SOLUTIONS I'M IS
PART OF WHY I'M PROUD THAT THIS
MEASURE HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
INFECTED WITH.
THIRTY SIX ZERO ON THE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR WHEN IT WHEN IT
PASSED OFF OF THE FLOOR AND DOWN.
ON SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CLOTHES.
SORRY --
SECRETARY SECTORAL CLEANS.
THE MOTION AS DO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUBBY HERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL AYE GALLAGHER REAVIS.
RIVERSIDE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I'VE VOEPEL I WILL TELL
AYE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE.
A S. B. THOSE WHOSE ME ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB.
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SENATOR WIENER
WELCOME
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF OUR
WITNESSES I THINK WE'LL TRY
MILLING AROUND OUTSIDE SOMEWHERE
SO.
WE'RE GONNA OCCUR SHORTLY I
THINK WAS A HUDDLE OF THAT YEAH
EXACTLY OUGHT TO SORT OF ONE
THAT SHARING CAN BE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AND I KNOW THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE STAFF
WORKED JOINTLY.
WITH US AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE WORKING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ON SO I ASK
YOU SEVEN SIXTY FIVE IS OUR
FOLLOW UP AND CLEAN UP --
LEGISLATION RELATING TO OUR S.
B. THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS A BILL I
AUTHORED AND THANK YOU --
MADAM CHAIR FOR SUPPORTING THAT
LAST YEAR OUGHT TO STREAMLINE
THE APPROVAL OF HOUSING AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS IN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE NOT --
MEETING THEIR RECENT HOUSING
NEEDS ASSESSMENT ON ARENA GOALS
ARE AND AS WE WENT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS ESPECIALLY AT THE END OF
THAT PROCESS WHEN IT WAS HER TO
LATE SOMETIMES TO MAKE SOME.
POT CLARIFICATIONS AND AS THE
BUILDING AND TO BE IMPLEMENTED
ARE WE WERE GATHERING FEEDBACK
FROM.
OUR PLANNING DEPARTMENTS AND
OTHERS --
DEL A LANGUAGE AND YOU TO BE
TIGHTENED OR CLARIFIED --
AND THAT IS --
DIED AS ARE THE THRUST --
OF THE BILL --
SO -- WE IN
WORKING WITH THE TWO COMMITTEES
OF WHAT WE DECIDE TO DO WAS MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME OF THE ASPECTS
OF THE BILLS.
SOME THE OTHERS WERE REALLY
MOVING I BILLION THIS COMMITTEE
OFFICIALLY --
AND THEN --
WE WORKING WITH BOTH COMMITTEES
OVER THE SUMMER --
WITH AN EYE TOWARD POTENTIALLY
RE INSERTING SOME OF THOSE
PROVISIONS MAYBE TRAP TO
DIFFERENTLY ON A FEW OF THEM
EACH CD MAY BE ABLE TO DO
ADMINISTRATIVELY SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK.
OF WITH BOTH COMMITTEES OUGHT
AND AFTER THE ANALYSIS CAN THAT
WE HAVE I KNOW SOME ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION SO.
I WE'RE AGREEING --
TO REAM.
ALL ASPECTS OF THE BILL EXCEPT
FOR ITEMS ONE E. FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN AYE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS --
AND IT WAS.
THREE VERA LISTED IN THE
COMMITTED ALICE'S PLUS THE LIEU
THE PREVAILING WAGE LABOR
CLARIFICATIONS.
YES OKAY OKAY GREAT --
SO WE ARE ACCEPTING IT AFTER ALL
THIS HOUSE LIVE ROCK LIKE MISTER
YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES HER YES.
ON AND SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US ARE SO THE BILL --
WILL MOVE FORWARD I INCLUDING A
CLARIFICATION.
ON THAT --
THAT THE OF APPROVAL OF A
DEVELOPMENT SHALL NOT CONSTITUTE
A PROJECT QUOTE UNQUOTE AND TO
SEE QUIRK --
CLARIFYING HELLO LABOR STANDARDS
APPLIED A MIXED USE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS A CLARIFYING
THAT REFERENCES TO PARKING
REQUIREMENTS.
ONLY APPLIED AUTOMOBILE PARKING
AUTOMOBILE.
AUTOMOBILE PARKING NOT BICYCLE
PARKING.
LOT AND CLARIFYING THE DECISIONS
TO GRAB OR ENTER INTO A
CONTRACTUAL LEASE AGREEMENT FOR
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
I WILL NOT CONSTITUTE A PROJECT
ON THE SEQUEL.
ODD SO WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WITH YOU TODAY OR IN
THE MIDDLE OF FROM BRIDGE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NONPROFIT DEVELOPER AND JEREMY
SMITH FROM OTHER BUILDING TRADES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE UNABLE REPRESENTING
BRIDGE HOUSING BRIDGE HOUSING IS
THE LARGEST NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER IN THE STATE --
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL AND PARTICULARLY THAT
COMPONENT THAT --
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT LEASES --
ARE EXCLUDED FROM SEQUEL --
WE ACTUALLY 5275% OF OUR
PROJECTS IN THE STATE --
THOUSANDS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
UNITS ARE DONE ON THIS TYPE OF
LAND AND TWO WERE VERY
APPRECIATIVE I ALSO JUST WANT TO
MENTION FOR THE RECORD THAT.
AREN'T EVEN THOUGH BRIDGE DOES
EVERYTHING FROM VERY VERY ULTRA
LOW INCOME HOUSING.
ARE ON UP WE'D DO TEND TO
FINANCE A LOT OF OUR PROJECTS IN
PART WITH THE LIMITATIONS AND
FINANCING.
ON A HIGHER LEVEL INCOME
PROJECTS MODERATE INCOME
PROJECTS TO HELP THE LOW AND
ULTRA LOW INCOME --
UNITS PENCIL OUT --
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS FATHERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
UP PLEASES PORTABILITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ARE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND MATTHEW
HUNG OVER THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND ALSO LIKE TO AND MOVE
FORWARD SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESS ISN'T HARD SAYING NONE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
AGAIN IF YOU NEED A MENTOR
MEMBERS YOU SLIGHTLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE HADN'T WAS LISTENING
POSITION WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR TAKING THE
COMMITTEES MINUTES AGO AS VERY
LONG WAIT AT ADDRESSING OUR
CONCERNS.
WE HAVE ONE LINGERING ISSUE BUT
WE ARE TO BEEN TALKING ABOUT A
WORLD FULL GET THERE APPRECIATED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
BUYING ACOSTA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
I'M ALSO ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER.
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
AGREED TO EARLIER AND HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND REITERATED HERE WE
ARE.
MOVING OUR OPPOSITION ON THE
BILL ALL PENDING SAYING THOSE
SUCH AMENDMENTS AND ALSO WORKING
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR WHAT
THE AUTHOR TO OF REFINED SOME OF
THE CLEANUP THAT.
WE ALL ANTICIPATED STILL NEEDED
THANK YOU.
SAY GEORGE WITH MY COMPLAIN
ASSOCIATION WERE IN THE SAME
POSITION WE WILL DEFINITELY BE
WORKING WITH AUTHORED THE
SPONSORS ON AMENDMENTS OVER THE
I GUESS JULY BREAK.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME TO
AGREEMENT AS WELL. TO MY VOICE
MATH URBAN CARRIES A CALIFORNIA
ALSO HAVE OFFICIALLY IN OPPOSE
POSITION WILL LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS BUT THEY DO GO A LONG
WAY REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES.
INTESTINE SPELLED THANK YOU.
IT ACTUALLY INTERESTS AROUND
RURAL COUNTY REPS AS A
CALIFORNIA BY MY COMMENTS WITH
THE SPEAKERS BEFORE ME WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT VERSION
ON BUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THAT.
BOTH COMMITTEES IN THE OFFICE
OFFICE THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF SEE SECOND
LIKE TO LIE MAKE COMMENTS WITH
APA'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE --
CENTER WIENER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHEN WE TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT TODAY RIGHT --
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING A BILL
FOR MY MAIN ONE IS ALWAYS IS
THAT THE STATE WAS OUR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS DONE.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR TAKING THE TIME IN JULY TO
TO DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ENSURE THAT THIS THAT S. B.
THIRTY FIVES IMPLEMENTED IN THE
STATUTE STATUTORY AND BIG GRIN.
AND BIG COMMITTEES SECOND TALK
TODAY -- ARE
CLARIFIED --
I LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING
THIS FURTHER AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE STATE COLLEGE
AGE CD AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
THANKS AGAIN I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I NEED A
MOTION.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
THE SECRETARY CULTURAL I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE EXCUSE ME.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIBEL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
IN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM I COVER HERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GRIEVOUS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
REPEL NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FAMILIES WHEN.
WE NEED ONE MORE VOTE WE HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE OUT SO.
WE'LL KEEP IT ON OFF GREAT THANK
YOU OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M MINDSHARE I SP.
LIGHTLY TWENTY IDIOTS.
ABOUT A MADAM CHAIR SP I THE
TWENTY AIDS ARE IS ARE A BILL
THE REFORMS ARE THE RESULT
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT ARENA
WHICH WE JUST TALKED ABOUT.
ARE KNOWN OR KNOWLEDGE THAT
SOMEONE OR BLOOM ALSO HAS A
READER REFORM BILL --
WE ARE -- IN
CONVERSATION THAT THE BILL'S.
HOW PERFECTLY I'M SURE THAT THEY
WILL LIVE IN THE AND SO LOOK FOR
THOSE CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS?
ARE AS A READ OF COURSE ISN'T
IMPORTANT TOOL OUGHT TO GUIDE
OUR COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE
HOUSING GOALS AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS MARKETRATE.
MODERATE --
LOW INCOME VERY LOW INCOME --
AND TO INFORM HOUSING ELEMENT
DECISIONS AND SO FORTH AUDRINA
HAS TAKEN ON ADDITIONAL
SIGNIFICANCE WITH THE PASSAGE.
OF SB THIRTY FIVE BECAUSE IT NOW
PLAYS INTO WHETHER COMMUNITY ARE
BECOME STREAMLINED SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET IT RIGHT --
ARENA -- AS
WE WENT THROUGH THE S. B. THIRTY
FIVE PROCESS LAST YEAR I THINK
THE ONE THING THAT.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE AGREED ON
WHATEVER SIDE THEY WERE ON IS
ARENA NEEDED SOME HELP ODD THAT
THERE IT WAS A VERY ODD
INEQUITABLE PROCESS.
ARE WE SEE --
A LOT OF TIMES WEALTHIER
[inaudible]
I'M COMMUNITIES --
POPULATION WISE GEOGRAPHICALLY
HAVING WHILE WILDLY DISPARATE --
READ ALLOCATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN THE MOST EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES.
AS OUGHT REDONDO BEACH --
WITH --
FOURTEEN HUNDRED REALLOCATION
OVER A YEAR'S A FOURTEEN HUNDRED
UNITS ITS NEIGHBORS HERMOSA AYE
MANHATTAN BEACHES --
WITH ALLOCATIONS RESPECTIVELY OF
TWO AND THIRTY SEVEN SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME EXTREME
DISPARITIES YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
I'M NOT PICKING ON YOUR DISTRICT
SOMEONE NUMBER BUT BEVERLY HILLS.
RECEIVE THE REALLOCATION OF TWO
UNITS OVER AN EIGHT YEAR
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE THIS IS
THE AND HAPPENS IN THE BAY AREA
AS WELL WITH SOME REALLY --
EXTREME --
EXTREMELY TO BIRDS AND SO ON IT
IS NOT IT IS EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
THROUGHOUT --
THE STATE.
I AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PUTTING GUARD RAILS AROUND
THE RING A PROCESS A RIGHT NOW.
ARE THE STATE BASICALLY
ALLOCATES LARGE QUANTITIES OF
HOUSING --
ON NUMBERS TO THE REGIONS TO THE
COGS AND THEN THE COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENT THAN GO THROUGH
BASICALLY A POLITICAL FOOD FIGHT.
TO DIVVY THAT UP AMONG THE
CITIES WITHIN THE READS AND I'M
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT MORE GUARD
US TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT SOUGHT
ALLOCATION.
IS DONE IN A MORE METHODICAL SO
S. B. TWENTY EIGHT I GIVE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE OUGHT TO EACH
CD ON HOW TO CALCULATE THE
BACKLOG OF EXISTING HOUSING NEED
BY READS AND BY IN A CRATE
INTEGRATING DATA ABOUT A VACANCY
RATE OVERCROWDING HOUSING COST
BURDEN SO WE'RE TRYING TO DIG.
OUT OF THE PAST HOLE WE CREATED.
UNDER IT ARE CURRENTLY AND WE
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES --
THAT COMMUNITIES ON FOR A 125%.
OUT OF THEIR ALLOCATION --
AND IT --
REQUIRES ACCOUNTS OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO FOCUS ON
CONCENTRATING GROWTH AND HIGH
OPPORTUNITY AREAS WITH GOOD
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
BOSSES BILL I THINK IS A GOOD
STEP FORWARD OTHER COMMITTEES
ARE SUGGESTED TO OUR AMENDMENTS
I ONCE ADDRESSED BOTH OF THEM
AND AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
BOTH OF THEM --
ONE VERY RELUCTANTLY AND OCHSNER
Y. BY WANNA ON WHICH WE WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND I KNOW WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THESE ISSUES.
OUGHT TO ONE OF THEM BY REMOVES
AN AMENDMENT THAT WAS PLACED
INTO THE BILL BY THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING COMMITTEE.
I AM AGNOSTIC ABOUT WHETHER IT
STAYS AND WRITTEN STAND I JUST
DON'T WANNA GET CAUGHT IN A VICE
BETWEEN TWO COMMITTEES.
SO WILL AGREE TO THE AMENDMENT
BUT WE WAS ASKED IF THE TWO
COMMITTEES COULD COMMUNICATE AND
WILL HOST TO WHAT WE'RE TOLD TO
DO AND APPROPRIATIONS EVEN TO
KEEP IT OUT OR PUT IT BACK IN.
STILL WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE --
GOING TO BE ACCUSED OF ADULTERY --
AND THEN THE SECOND ARE THE
COMMITTEE HAS RECOMMENDED AGREE
I REDUCING THE RENA ZONING
ALLOCATION FROM A 125% 2100%.
ON ALTHOUGH --
THIS ISSUE IS NOT AT THE HEART
OF THE BILL RIGHT BEFORE IT'S
MAKING SURE WE I'M.
MORE GUARDRAILS AROUND HOW THOSE
SUB ALLOCATIONS HAPPEN ON I DO
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT THE
REASON WHY WE INCREASE AT ABOUT
A 100%.
IS TO ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES
ARE ACTUALLY HITTING A 100%
BECAUSE WHEN COMMUNITY ZONE FOR
EXACTLY A 100%.
THERE'S ALWAYS GONNA BE REASONS
WHY PRIDE.
SOME PROJECTS DON'T HAVE BEEN
EARLY AT THE LATE WHERE THEY'RE
BUILT ON THE ZONING AND THEN IT
MAKES IT ARE MUCH LESS LIKELY TO
COMMUNITIES.
WILL HIT A 100%.
WE BELIEVE A 125% WILL MAKE IT
MORE LIKELY TO COMMUNITIES WILL
HAVE A 100%.
OUGHT IN ADDITION ARE KEEPING IT
A 100% I WILL MEAN THERE ARE
FEWER PARCELS AVAILABLE FOR
MULTI UNIT WHICH MEANS IT'S
HARDER FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS THAT'S EXACTLY THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE THAT IN THERE
WASN'T.
AN ARBITRARY LET'S STICK IT TO
THE CITIES ARE THERE WITH A A
REAL POLICY BASIS FOR DOING THAT
ARE BUT I DO UNDERSTAND THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE US TO GO TO
A HUNDRED OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE
COMMITTEE IN DEFERENCE WERE.
WILL ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT SO
WITH THAT SAID I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I WITH ME TODAY ARE AS
OUR CORNELIUS BURKE FROM THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL ONE OF OUR SPONSORS
THE MICHAEL LANE FROM THE
NONPROFITHOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU WELCOME SETTLEMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE CORNELIUS
BURKE WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL.
REPRESENT THREE HUNDRED THE TOP
EMPLOYERS AND NINE O'CLOCK CAN I
COUNTY BEAR REGION.
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE ON PRESIDENT
HOUSING CRISIS AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WHEN THIS CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE ALL THIS LOW SUPPLY.
BUT ALSO WE HAVE AN ADEQUATE AND
SMARTLY PLANNED FOR HOUSING.
ARE THIS BILL GETS HAS ACCURATE
MET DATA.
ACRID METHODOLOGY TO REALLY GET.
AND ADEQUATE PLANNING OF WITH
THAT WE PRESENT FEE OUT FROM AYE
THOUGH.
THANK YOU WALTER AYE AYE CURRY
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL AIM AT THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE REIGN OF REFORM AND
MODERNIZATION.
S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT THE SCARCITY
OF PROPERTIES ON MULTI FAMILY
SIZE THEIR COMPETITIVE PER STATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
PROGRAMS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
ADDRESSES BY REQUIRING A
JURISDICTIONS OWN FOR MORE SUCH
SITES.
THIS REPORTEDLY SOME DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON SKYROCKETING LAND
PRICES AND SH ASSURE SUFFICIENT
PARCELS ARE AVAILABLE.
THIS PARTICULAR IMPORTANT FOR
PLACES LIKE THE BAY AREA WERE
LACKING GO FOR MORE THAN TEN
MILLION DOLLARS AN ACRE UP FOR
MORE.
IT TAKES THREE INGREDIENTS TO
DEVELOP AFFORDABLE HOUSING LAND
FUNDING AND POLITICAL WILL TO
GET PROJECTS APPROVED.
IF WE'RE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS WE NEED
THESE THREE INGREDIENTS.
THE METHODOLOGY CALLED FOR AN SP
TWENTY EIGHT TO ASSESS THE TRUE
HOUSING NEED WILL PROVIDE BOTH
GREATER ACCURACY.
AND EQUITY IN THOSE RANDOM
NUMBERS.
AND JUST SUSPECT THIS 125% ARENA
WERE REALLY PROTECT PERPLEXED BY
THE THE ANGST OVER THIS IS
ACTUALLY A BEST PRACTICE SOME
JURISDICTIONS ARE YOU DO IT.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A REQUIREMENT THE
STATE LEVEL FOR THE FOR THE
REASONS ASIDE BUT MY CENTER
WINNER AND WE REALLY SUPPORT THE
BILL AS IT CURRENTLY.
EXISTS BUT WILL.
WE'LL GO ALONG WITH THE WILL OF
THE AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE BUT I
JUST NEED TO MAKE THAT POINT.
WE NEED LAND BUILDABLE LAND
MULTI FAMILY LAND 125% IS NOT AN
EXCESSIVE ASK A AT ALL WE WISH
THAT WOULD WOULD STAY IN THE
BILL.
AND WE REQUEST DRIVER.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I THINK I'M CHAIRING KEYSTONE
HERE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WERE
WORKING FINE MANY SOLUTIONS TO
TRY AND HOME FIND HOMES FOR OUR
CITIZENS.
THINK SP TWENTY EIGHT'S A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE HELP
KEEP THE BILL'S STRONGEST
POSSIBLE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO PRIME YOU
HAVE A FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
SENATOR MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON
BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAMANTLY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICK BROKE A HIM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
MADISON Y. ON BEHALF THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BE AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANDREAS FISCHER WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS A CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
LIKE SHEPARD REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT.
DUNCAN MCFETRIDGE REPRESENTING
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SPORT.
TIFFANY FAN OF HOW THE BRIDGE
HOUSING SUPPORT.
MATTHEW HARPER THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN THE BUILDING OWNERS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE HINTS PART.
SING NONE ON THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
EITHER CLOSELY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE HADN'T OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THEY GO
A VERY LONG WAY TOWARDS
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS.
WE DO STILL WANT TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT SECTION
FOR LANGUAGE WHICH TALKS ABOUT
THE INTENT BEHIND RINA BY THINK
WE'RE HOPEFUL WE CAN WORK
SOMETHING OUT ON THAT AND REMOVE
OPPOSITION SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SENATE GEORGE OF AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION OR IN THE
SAME POSITION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS --
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A POINT TO I
KNOW THE BILL THAT THE HOW 225%
IS OUT OF THE BILL.
BUT THE BEST PRACTICES ISSUE HAS
CHANGED SINCE LAST YEAR THERE
WERE TWO BILLS THAT MANDATED
THAT THERE BE I'M VERY VISIBLE
SITES.
THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND AND ALSO IN
THE EVENT THAT THERE ARE SITES
THAT ARE LOST BY INCOME LEVEL
THERE'S A NO NET LOSS
REQUIREMENT NOW.
ON THAT HAS CHANGED THE WAY THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING SO WE'LL BE
DOING ROLLING OWING TO MAKE SURE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WERE IN THE
SAME BOAT AS A PRIOR TO SPEAKERS
APPRECIATE THE OTHER TAKEN THE
AMENDMENTS LOOK FOR WORKING ON
IT OVER THE SUMMER TIME
HOPEFULLY WE GET THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JULY FOURTH URBAN CARRIES A
CALIFORNIA ALSO APPEAR CA
OPPOSING US MANDATE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
MCGUIRE COMMENTS THEY PAY ITS
EXACT THING.
TRACY RYAN ROEKIAH REP SAYS
CALIFORNIA LIMA COMES WITH THOSE
BEFORE ME THANK YOU --
DAVID JONES OF AFTER GLENDALE
THE CITY'S MARIN AT MY WE GRIEVE
THEIR COLLEAGUES.
THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GIVEN MY SHOULDER.
BECAUSE WE HAVE MOTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM.
OKAY THE SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER
GABREL --
LET'S SEE HERE ANY COMMENTS --
TO CENTER WIENER YES --
OF JUST BE BRIEF --
AS OF THE SENATOR OUT A
MENTIONED EARLIER WE BOTH HAVE
BILLS ON THE TOPIC OF ARENA
REFORM THEY TAKE --
DIFFERENT APPROACHES BUT SHARE A
SIMILAR GOAL AND STILL NEED TO
WORK OUT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE TWO BILLS AND I APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR'S COMMITMENT TO DO
THAT AND HE CERTAINLY HAS.
HAS MY COMMITMENTS SO --
ON FOR THOSE WHO BREAK A FOR A
LEGISLATORS --
AND EVERYBODY HERE IS HERE IN
THIS ROOM IS --
YOU KNOW A GOING TO CAMP --
IT WON'T BE WE'RE ALL GOING TO
BE WORKING ON THINGS LIKE THIS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVE BRING
THIS TO RESOLUTION [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
YES.
THE MEMBER VOEPEL.
GREAT.
SENATOR WIENER I'M GLAD TO SEE
YOU DO ALL OF YOUR AMENDMENTS IN
THE CONTINUING WORK I WAS.
OPPOSITION I'LL BE A NO VOTE OUT
OF RESPECT SIR.
OKAY ANYONE OTHER COMMENTS --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH US AND THE READER PROCESS
HAS DRIVEN ME NUTS FOR A LONG
TIME.
AND A KIND OF TIGHTENED UP ZERO
BETTER I REALLY APPRECIATE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO THE COGS IN
ALL OF THE SUDDEN YOU GET THIS
NUMBER AND YOU CAN GO.
INTO TOWN A SEVEN THOUSAND YOU
WANT ME TO DO WHAT --
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING SO ANYWAY
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU --
I'D LIKE TO HAVE MORE
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS BECAUSE THAT
SOMETHING I'M INTERESTED IN AS
WELL SO WITHOUT --
IT'S TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND I WOULD ACTUALLY NINE CHAIR
ON I AM NOT.
WITH RESPECT TO BOTH OF THESE
BILLS THE IT GETS VERY TECHNICAL
SOMETIMES WE TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW IT'S CLEAN UP THIS IS
CLEAN UP IS IS NOT CLEAN OUT ITS
RENA -- IT'S
THE CALL EXITS ASIDE AND THE
OTHER THING A LOT OF ACRONYMS
AND YOU KNOW.
WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW OUR
CITIES ARE COUNTIES WHO DON'T
WANT US EVER TELLING THEM.
WHAT TO DO --
BUT I I REALLY THINK --
AND TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE I
THINK WE HAVE TO SOMETIMES AS
POLICY MAKERS STEP AWAY FROM THE
ACRONYMS AND FIGHTS ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL.
AND TALK ABOUT ON THAT AT THE
ACTUAL HUMAN ASPECT OF THIS.
AND WE HAVE A SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA THREE AND A HALF
MILLION HOMES --
DOT SHORTAGE IS EQUAL TO THE
SHORTAGE OF THE OTHER FORTY NINE
STATES COMBINED A SAY THAT AGAIN.
OUR DEFICIT OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IS EQUAL TO THE OTHER
FORTY NINE STATES COMBINED.
UP WE HAVE A HUGE AND GROWING
HOMELESS POPULATION AND IT'S NOT
JUST PEOPLE WHO ARE SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL THAT IS ONE
COMPONENT.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING --
WHO ARE BRINGING THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL IN THE MORNING AND YOU
ARE LIVING IN THEIR CARS OR IN
SHELTERS OR OTHER PLACES WHERE
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE LIVING?
IS ASTOUNDING IN SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ALONE
WE'VE [inaudible]
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED HOMELESS
CHILDREN.
WE HAVE CHILLED KIDS WHO GO AWAY
TO COLLEGE WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO
RETURN BACK TO THE TOWN THEY
GREW UP IN ITS IMPOSSIBLE MUSTER
IN A LIVE.
IN THEIR PARENTS BASEMENT WE
HAVE YOUNG FAMILIES WHO ARE NOT
WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO MAKE IT TO
HAVE THAT SECOND KID AND THEY'RE
GONE.
OFTEN LEAVING CALIFORNIA TIGHTLY
IT IS DEBILITATING OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE GOALS
AS PEOPLE ARE PUSHING THE TWO
HOUR COMMUTES.
IT IS UNDERMINING OUR CONDO ME
AS EMPLOYERS SAY I'M GONNA
EXPAND ELSEWHERE BECAUSE MY
WORKERS CAN'T FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE HERE.
THESE ARE REAL ISSUES WITH
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL.
AND HUMAN IMPACTSAND WE KNOW
THAT WHEN THERE IS DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON HOUSING.
ARE IT IS OUR LOWEST INCOME
RESIDENTS --
WHO ARE ALWAYS THE ONES WHO WERE
HURT I'VE BEEN MOST I AM
GREATEST RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS AND JUST BEING PUSH ON
TIGHTLY?
ARE SO WE CAN HAVE ALL THE
DEBATES --
WITH ALL OF OUR FRIENDS HERE
ABOUT WELL YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT YOU TO TELL US WHAT --
TO TO WE DON'T YOU KNOW WE WERE
GOING TO QUIBBLE WITH THIS SO
THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
ACRONYMS.
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE PEOPLE
HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE --
AND I JUST I AND I I'M AND I
KNOW WE ALL WANT TO KEEP OUR I
ON THAT BALL BUT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
TIME WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE TERRY CULTURAL.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED IN
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ADWARE CURRY.
ADWARE CARRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM I COPY AERO CABALLERO AYE
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
REAVIS.
REAVIS I'VE RUBIO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
WITHOUT FIVE ZERO IF YOU THINK
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP ONE
FOUR ONE SIX SENATOR MCGUIRE
WELCOME.
HOW DO YOU?
I THINK U. SO MUCH AYE MADAM
CHAIR IN TWO SIMILAR BLOOM ON
MAKE IT AS FORTY FIVE SECONDS.
LONG STORY SHORT --
WORKING GROUP WAS ESTABLISHED
THIS PAST FALL AFTER THE TRAGIC
GO SHIP FIRE.
BUT ALL STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
FORM TWO BILLS AYE YOUR AYE NEW
CONSULTANT AYE JIMMY AND ANTON
WERE FANTASTIC I'M BRINGING
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS FORWARD.
HIGH AND IT WILL NOT ONLY
PROTECT THOSE WERE LIVING ON A
ALSO PROVIDES A PROCESS AYE IF
VIOLATIONS ARE DISCOVERED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WE DO HAVE CARRY SIMPSON OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SERVICES MANAGER
FOR THE CITY RANCHO CORDOVA HERE
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION IN THE COMMAND CHAIR FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORKING STAFF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHICH TYPES.
YES HI AND ALSO HELP ALWAYS HERE
I'M CARRY SIMPSON --
I'M HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ACCORDING POST
OFFICES AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR ON THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT HE'S DONE.
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT BEING
ABLE TO LEAN FINES AND FEES AND
I WANT.
TO REITERATE THESE ON NEW FINES
AND FEES THESE ARE --
FEES ARE ALL A BABY PROPERTY
OWNERS THAT DON'T WANT TO DO SO.
UP BEING GIVEN THE AUTHORITY TO
LEAN THE PROPERTIES IS JUST ONE
OF THE WAY THAT WE WILL ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO CURE THE ISSUE AND SO
THANK YOU WE REALLY AND
REQUESTED I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER IN --
SUPPORTER.
MATTHEW HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
I'M NOT GONNA SIT DOWN BUT I'D
LOVE TO DO A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN JUST A ME TOO ON THAT.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT THE THE
THE BUSINESS PROPERTIES THAT
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES OUT THERE.
AND NORMALLY WERE NOT HERE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
SOMETHING THAT COULD.
COULD BE A NEW A FINE ON US
HOWEVER WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH SEVERAL DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE SEVERAL DIFFERENT
AUTHORS AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS AUTHOR.
I HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE GHOST SHIP FIRE WAS
ADDRESSED APPROPRIATELY.
AT IT IT REALLY PUT OUR INDUSTRY
INTO.
AN AWKWARD POSITION HAVE BECAUSE
THE PROPERTY THAT DID BURN DOWN.
IS ZONED COMMERCIAL AND IT'S
CALLED A WAREHOUSE BUT IS NOT
OPERATING AS A COMMERCIAL
WAREHOUSE --
SO OUR INITIAL.
STERN WAS THAT WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS SOMETHING MOVE
FORWARD THAT WE COULD WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO YOU DISTINGUISH THESE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE ON THE EDGE
AND THAT ARE ARE MERGING.
FROM ONE USE TO ANOTHER AND WE
ALSO HAD THE CONCERN THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
BUILDINGS IN COMMERCIAL AREAS
THAT ARE COMING BACK LIKE OUR
STREET CORRIDOR DID NOT HAVE
IMPEDIMENTS TO THEM --
THAT STOPPED THEM FROM BECOMING
REALLY NEAT ART SPACES LIKE THAT
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
CAL BONE EVERYONE ELSE WAS WORK
ON THIS WE HEARD IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS.
AND WE I THINK THE COMMITTEE
ENERGY TO VOTE YES.
HI XIN DEALER WITH A CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS COWBELL AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THINK THE AUTHOR SARAH MCGUIRE
FOR THEIR EFFORTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT SENATOR MYERS BILL
THINKING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREATER ME WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
OF COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
WE NEED A SECOND HALF OF MR
LIMITED THE FOR RESTLESSLY.
I FOR SOME MEMBER CARILLO --
SENATOR I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FOR THAT WAS THE
PROBLEM ON THE MOST TRAGIC
EVENTS.
WE'VE SEEN TOO MUCH TRAGEDY
BEHIND YOU AND I WAS NOT SURE --
BUT IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE FOLLOW UP TO
MAKE SURE WE DO THE RIGHT THING.
AYE WHILE THE ENSIGN ASSESSMENTS
ARE POWERFUL TOOLS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REALLY BELIEVE
THIS BILL PRESENTS AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE.
BY LIMITING ITS PROVISIONS TO A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD AND AT THE
KINDS OF PROBLEMS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE GHOST SHIP
FIRE -- AND
I WILL BE VOTING IN AYE AYE AND
I THINK FOR ALL OF YOU WHO
WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS IS.
IT'S A SHAME WE HAD HAVE TO DO
THINGS RIGHT SO ANYWAY --
LET'S RIVER MOTION WOULD JUDGE
CLOSE HIS HER SAY I THINK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
I HAD THE HONOR OF BEING ABLE --
TO PARTNER WITH AS THEY HAVE
WONDERFUL CHAIR IN LAKE COUNTY
IN NYC YOU SAID WE'RE
DISAPPEARANCE SUNDAY TOGETHER.
TRAGEDY THERE I THIS WAS A
DEVASTATING EVENT FOR CITY OF
OAKLAND AYE AS WELL AS THE STATE
GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK IN
THINK YOU WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I DON'T.
THINK YOU.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY
ACT WHERE CURRY AYE WALDRON
BLOOM.
BLOOM I COVER GYRO COMPASS ZERO
AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL AYE
GALLAGHER REAVIS.
REAVIS I RUBIO LAPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
BILLS UP [inaudible]
FIVE ONE THANK YOU. FOR I WERE
WAITING FOR OUR LAST AUTHOR.
LOOKING FOR SENATOR HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
YEAH.
COMEY HEROES HERE [inaudible]
JUST [inaudible]
ON ROADS
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GOING --
TO MILLION NEW. TO UNDER THE
SURFACE.
OTHER SB SEVEN SIXTY FIVE WIENER
VOTE CURRENT VOTE IS
[inaudible]
FOUR ZERO BILLS OUT.
BILLS UP FIVE ZERO SORRY.
WHEN WHEN DO WE HAVE?
I NEVER KNEW ADAMS
.
ITEM NUMBER FOR SENATE BILL TEN
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CUBBY ARROW.
KABIRA I ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATE
BILL TWELVE SIXTY JACKSON AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO BE REFERRED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE COVER
GYRO [inaudible]
CUMPLIR I REAVIS.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SIX REAVIS I ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY EIGHT THIS IS THE
RECOMMEND CONSENT CABALLERO.
KOBE AYE REAVIS [inaudible]
CONSENT [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE.
CHRIS WAITED FOR CENTER
HERTZBERG
.
THE TITLE OF THE SUIT IS.
BUT WHAT GOOD IS THIS.
A JOKE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B.
TWELVE FIFTEEN SENATOR HERTZBERG
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO VERY VERY MUCH --
YOU KNOW HAS YOU KNOW THE MOST
OF YOU KNOW I'M CHAIRMAN OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES IN WATER
COMMITTEE.
AND I FOCUS A WITH GREAT
ATTENTION ON THE ISSUE OF WATER.
WE ARE TRYING TO RETHINK IN
EVERY CONTEXT OF THIS ISSUE OF
WATER HOW.
WE DELIVER CLEAN WATER IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY A ACROSS THE
BOARD SO WE'RE DOING.
A STORM WATER CAPTURE AND
RECYCLING AND WE JUST DID IT
WITH THE SUMMER FRIEDMAN A BIG
BILL DEALING WITH WATER
EFFICIENCY.
BUT ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE IS CEREMONIES IN
WORKING ON THIS STUFF IS WE'VE
GOT A LOT COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH VARIOUS SOME OF THE
REASONS I JUST DON'T GET ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER PRICKLY RURAL
AREAS IT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
WE'VE THREE HUNDRED WATER
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE OF WATER THAT'S WORST IN
FLINT MICHIGAN.
IF IT IS RIDICULOUS RIGHT AND
AND AND SO WE TRY TO CORRECT ONE
OF THOSE PROCESS DIFFUSE AGO
WITH SENATOR WALK AND SENATOR
LENO.
WHERE ONE THE WATER SUPPLY
SYSTEM WE TRIED TO INTO THESE
RURAL COMMUNITIES A CRATE SOME
CONSOLIDATION WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN THIS BILL?
IS WE ARE DOING THE SAME THING
BUT FOR WAIT THANKS THAT TO
REALLY ADVERSE COMMUNITIES YOU
CAN HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES
TODAY WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
TAKE CARE OF THAT STUFF IN A BE
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO PASS.
A LISTENER MINING'S BILL BUT NO
ONE WANTS TO PASS A TAX THIS
MORNING A I HAD A HEARING ON THE
THE THE BOND THE WATER BOND
ISSUE TO COST FOUR HUNDRED AND
SOME MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. TO
PAY FOR THAT BOND THAT YOU BE
WILLING TO SAW HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OFFER THAT AND USE THAT
MONEY FOR THE NEXT FORTY YEARS
TAKE CARE COMMITTEES THAT NEED
WATER. FOR CLEAN CLEAN WATER FOR
COMMITTEES THAT ARE THAT ARE RA
IN TROUBLE.
COURSE KNOCKED BUT WHATEVER IT'S
JUST I WANTED TO MAKE THE PUBLIC
POLICY POINT AS WE LOOK AT THESE
PRICE THESE THESE IDEAS
HOLISTICALLY SO THIS IS PART OF
MY CHARGE IF YOU WILL.
AS I SEE IT. TO COMPREHENSIVELY
LOOK AT WATER POLICY WITH A FEW
SEPTIC TANKS AND SIMILAR BOAT
REACH LOUISE DE LOS LOUISE
REVERSES DISTRICT DR.
AT THE US DISTRICT IN MY
DISTRICT WE OVERLAP BUT NOT A
LOT BUT THIS IS MORE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW THAT AFFECTS
A NUMBER OF OTHER MEMBERS HERE
[inaudible]
YOUR DOCTOR [inaudible]
DR.
BEACH DIESEL DR.
OBJECT TO IT YOUR DOCTOR TO ME.
SO WITH THAT I'LL PROBABLY
WITNESSES.
DR EUROPE DOCTOR OF LAWS.
SHE'S AT MIT DR.
WE JUST HAD THIS NUMERACY SEVEN
IS A LIVING GOING ACKERMAN ALAN
NARAL CANNELLA IF IT'S NOT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE
SEVEN SALUTE YOU AND I COME FROM
THE COMEDIAN LET AARON FRESNO
COUNTY.
YEP ALL YOUR LIFE THAT BAY THOSE
THAT YOU THINK.
MR COMMITTED AT THE END A AYE
FUNGUS THAT BECAUSE LOOK WHAT IS
THE FULL JOHN UP A BIT I MEANT
THE I SUPPORT S. B. TWELVE
FIFTEEN AM MY COMMUNITY RELIES
ON SEPARATE THINGS WHICH DON'T
FUNCTION ADEQUATELY.
NEWMAN OWNER WITH THEM WHICH
WOULD MONTH AN IMMENSE.
NUMBER ONE IT'S REALLY AND
EXPENSIVE TO MAINTAIN.
NEW MODELS I'M WHICH A SINGLE
MILLIONS YES THERE'S A LOT OF
INCONVENIENCE BUT HIM.
WHEN I SEE NOW THAT MICHAEL
MONEY THAT'S NOT WHERE THE
NURSES VEHICLES A. B. C. THANK?
FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF MY NEIGHBORS
AND MY COMMUNITY CAN'T HAVE HER
GRANDCHILDREN OVER FOR A VISIT.
BUT AGAIN THANK IN OF THE
INITIAL VISIT THE CAPACITY THAT
BUT NO SUBSIDY BECAUSE THIS EPIC
THINK DOES NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY TO BE USED YES ONE UP
IN A STATEMENT OF THE ONE OF ME.
AND IT'S A SHAME BECAUSE THE
WASTE BACKS UP INTO THE HOME BUT
ELECT ASSN.
AUTOPSY ON GET THE ENOUGH
PERSONAS CAN WHISTLER
OPERABILITY CORRECT.
IF WE ADDRESS PASAS A COMBO
EQUALITY BOXER A SUBSTANTIAL.
IS AN TO PUMP AYE SEPTIC TANKS
OUT INTO THE OPEN FIELDS WHICH
CREATES GROUNDWATER ISSUES.
ECONOMY NOT ALLOW WORK.
BUT LIKE WHAT.
DAVINA LONELY THAT THOSE AND
CONTAMINATE OUR WATER WHICH IS
WHERE MY TRIP TO COME FROM IT IT
WHETHER ROSY LEFT ALONE ELECT.
AND CAN I BECAUSE SOMEONE OUR
THE MINUTE WE GET IS THOSE
ASSIDUOUS AYE COMPOTE AYE BUT I
DO THINK CLOSE.
BUT IF YOU COME OUT ON TO THE
FIELD ALSO ATTRACTS INSECTS
ALMOST GOT HIS AND PHOTOS MIKE
FLIES AND MOSQUITOES.
GET THE NINE IT'S OF CONTAMINANT
THIS OTHER SPECIALISTS.
BUT BRING CAN HOW NATION TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR FAMILIES IS
THEM IN THE EYES OF BAKED BOTH
THE KEY THING.
I DO ATTY AND RESPECT AMONG THE
BUT I SAID I'M A HORNET'S.
IT'S BETTER IF THEY THIS OPINION
IS THAT WITH S. B. TALKED
FIFTEEN WOULD HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES ON HELP MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN MY COMMUNITY AND
I HOPE YOU ALSO SUPPORTED AS
WELL.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON AND MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BUT ONLY GOT THAT YOU
AYE I'M WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
AS HE SURVEYED STATED THERE ARE
HUNDREDS ED AND THE SENATOR --
MADE TALK ABOUT THEIR HUNDREDS
OF COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING MANY IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND IN THE
EASTERN CULTURAL VALLEY WHICH WE
WORK WITH DIRECTLY.
THAT RELY ON DILAPIDATED SEPTIC
TANKS AND OTHER.
DON'T ALLOW FAMILIES TO BE ABLE
TO LIVE IN A DIGNIFIED WAY IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES AND ALLOWS
CREATES I AM OPPORTUNE CREATES --
UNFORTUNATE SCENARIOS WHERE
CHILDREN OFTENTIMES HAVE TO PLAY
IN YARDS WHERE THERE'S RAW
SEWAGE IN AND AROUND THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS --
AND IT FOR MOST OF THESE
COMMUNITIES MANY OF THEM ARE
WITHIN A MILE --
WITHIN A MILE OR EVEN A FEW
HUNDRED YARDS OF A MUNICIPAL
WASTEWATER SYSTEM THAT IT ONLY
THOSE LINES WERE EXTENDED THOSE
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE A PART OF
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN.
A DIGNIFIED WAY AND BE ABLE TO
IMPROVE THEIR COMMUNITY AND SEEK
A BETTER --
INVESTMENTS IN THAT AREA AS WELL
AND SO WITH THAT TODAY AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF WRONGS THAT WE
THOUGHT THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
TALKED ABOUT TODAY AND THIS IS
ONE WRONG THAT WE CAN HELP RIGHT.
BY MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS HIS AYE
WASTEWATER SERVICE IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU PAT CHO JONES IS YOUR
CALIFORNIANS APART THINKING.
TREES A BURGAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL DIRECTORS OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
SERIES IN SUPPORT.
PHOEBE SCENE ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER CLEAN
WATER ACTION Q. IN A SAY HI IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN THE THEREMIN MOMENT OUT OF
A HUNDRED AND LIT UP WE HEARD
YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE JUST THE?
LATISYS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LANA
GOT BEHIND IN MY COME FROM THE
COMMUNION WHEN THEY'RE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MISSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS HAD JUST CA.GOV AT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES HERE TODAY.
OF RELUCTANTLY HERE --
TO EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AS IT WAS AMENDED --
LAST FRIDAY SO --
WITH THE AMENDMENTS LAST FRIDAY
WE'RE STILL SORTING THROUGH --
YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
IMPACT OUR WASTE WATER AGENCIES
BUT THERE.
ARE A FEW SPECIFIC COMPONENTS
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
FOR US THOUGH.
A ONE OF THOSE BEING THE NEW
LANGUAGE ON PAGE SIX THAT ALLOWS --
REGIONAL BOARD TO ORDER AN
EXTENT.
WITH ACCESS CAPACITY AND THEN
GIVES THE STATE BOARD THE RIGHTS
TO THAT EXCESS CAPACITY FOR FIVE
YEARS WITHOUT PAYING THE
CONNECTION FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT ADDITIONAL CAPACITY --
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT A LOCAL AGENCIES
DO DUE PROCESS RIGHTS GIVEN THE
NEW AMENDMENTS I WON'T GET INTO
THE DETAILS THERE --
BUT THERE AT SEVERAL SPECIFIC
THINGS THEY'VE BEEN OUTLINED BY
SOME OF OUR A MEMBER AGENCIES
THAT THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT --
WE DO KNOW THAT THE POLICY
HANDBOOK OUTLINED IN THE BILL
SHOULD BE CLARIFIED AS TO
WHETHER IT'S A BINDING
REGULATORY DOCUMENT OR IF IT'S A
FLEXIBLE GUIDANCE DOCUMENT --
AND THEN WE HAVE SOME PRACTICAL
CONCERNS WITH JUST HOW THIS
PROCESS WOULD WORK ON THE GROUND
SO.
AND IT'S IT'S UNCLEAR WHO WOULD
DETERMINE THE COSTS OF
INTERCONNECTION --
WHETHER THE FEES ARE REASONABLE --
IMPORTANTLY WHAT FORM THE
REGIONAL BOARDS ORDER WOULD TAKE
SO IS IT AND ENFORCEMENT ORDER
AGAINST THE LOCAL AGENCY AND WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE SINCE THE LOCAL
AGENCY HADN'T.
HAD A WATER QUALITY VIOLATION --
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THESE ACTIONS
WOULD WORK WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH MULTIPLE LOCAL AGENCIES SO
IN SOME CASES THE CITY MIGHT OWN
AND OPERATE A COLLECTION SYSTEM
THAT'S THE CLOSEST.
ADJACENT SYSTEM TO THIS
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY BUT
THERE'S ALSO THAT SECONDARY
LAYER OF A CONTROL AGENCY WHICH
IS A DOWNSTREAM AGENCY THAT
WOULD BE MAKING DETERMINATIONS.
ABOUT TREATMENT CAPACITY
CONNECTION FEES THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS SO --
UNDER THE PROVISION.
AMENDED ON FRIDAY I'M IT'S CLEAR
WHETHER THAT ORDER WOULD --
APPLY TO BOTH OF THESE ENTITIES.
IT'S ADDRESS SO I'M WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SEE SOME STRONGER
LANGUAGE ON THE SERVICE
EXTENSIONS BEING COMPLIANT WITH
PROP TWO EIGHTEEN THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO
THE SENDER STUFF ABOUT.
FURTHER UP IN SEVERAL MONTHS --
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT ADEQUATE
FINANCING FOR THE FOR EVERY
SINGLE AND EXTENSION OF SERVICE.
BE SECURED PRIOR TO THE
EXTENSION BEING ORDERED AND THEN
WE'D LIKE TO SEEK SOME FURTHER
CLARITY ON THE TYPES OF
COMMUNITIES THAT THE BILL'S
TARGETING SO.
AND I JUST WANNA FINALLY NOTE
THAT WE ARE NOT OBJECTING IN ANY
WAY -- TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES WITH FEELING SEPTIC
SYSTEMS.
WE CERTAINLY EMPATHIZE WITH THE
SITUATIONS AND OUR MEMBERS ARE
IN EXISTENCE TO PROTECT WATER
QUALITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PROVIDE SEWER SERVICE. TO
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THAT SO
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
REFLECTS THE REASONABLE.
AND WORKABLE PROCESS AND WE
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T FEEL THAT
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY GETS
THERE FOR US SO MUCH THAT WE
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR COMMENTS
THEN -- WERE
OPEN TO CONTINUING THIS
CONVERSATION WITH CENTER
HERTZBERG GONNA STOP AT THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARIAN
WARMER DOWN THE ROAD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
A WE DO NOT HAVE AN OPPOSED
POSITION JUST TO CLARIFY BUT WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS SIMILAR TO
MY COLLEAGUE AND WE HAVE SOME
PROCESS CONCERNS BUT LET ME TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WERE NOT MENTIONED.
BOMB ON THE POSITIVE SIDE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY
DEFINITION OF INCLUDED IN THE
BILL IT CAPTURES MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES.
THAT THERE ARE IN OUR MEMBER
COUNTIES THAT.
GET CONSIDERATIONS SO I JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT WE REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THAT.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE --
THE INTERESTS OF THE SENATOR
HOUSING ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS ARE THESE CONCERNS
THESE ARE NOT NEW ISSUES AS WAS
ACKNOWLEDGED EARLIER THIS IS THE
IF YOU WILL THE MIRROR IMAGE OF
THE ISSUE THAT SENATOR MONNING
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS IN HIS
MEASURE.
A WE HAVE THE SAME SORT OF SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES AS IT WERE.
FROM OUR EXPERIENCE FIND IN THE
CAPITAL TO PUT IN THE FACILITIES
TO ADDRESS IN THIS CASE A NEED
FOR A SOURCE SYSTEM.
IS NOT THE ISSUE WHERE WE START
GETTING SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE
COMMUNITIES IS THE O. THE
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE COSTS
THAT GO ALONG WITH SUPPORTING
THESE FACILITIES.
IN MANY OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES DO NOT
HAVE THE ECONOMIC WHEREWITHAL.
TO SUPPORT THE FACILITY AND
GIVEN THE CONSTRAINTS FROM PROP
TWO EIGHTEEN A AND OTHER SIMILAR.
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS WE'RE IN
A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION IN
TERMS OF BRINGING THESE
FACILITIES TO LIFE.
SO WE WE DO WANT TO WORK WITH
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S A
PROBLEM.
WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE IF THERE
WERE A MARKET BASED APPROACH TO
THESE SITUATIONS WE'D OF HAD
PLENTY OF TIME TO IDENTIFY THEM
AND BRING THEM TO LIFE BUT
THAT'S NOT BEEN THE CASE.
I'M I WOULD ALSO.
OF ONE LAST COMMENT.
IS THAT THE THE CURRENT PROCESS
THAT'S BEEN ARTICULATED BECAUSE
OF THE MULTIPLICITY.
OF ENTITIES THAT MIGHT BE
INVOLVED BETWEEN A RURAL COUNTY
WHERE YOU HAVE.
EVERYTHING FROM A SMALL CITY TO
A CS A COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT TO UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES TRYING TO FIND THE
RIGHT PATH FOR WORD. TO BRING
ALL THESE DISPARATE ENTITIES
INTO THE PROCESS BUT WE BELIEVE
IT NEEDS ON A LITTLE BIT OF
ADDITIONAL THOUGHT AND WORK IN
TERMS OF GETTING US THERE --
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE ENTRY
PRODUCTIVE.
A PARTICIPANT IN THE
CONVERSATION WE JUST DON'T FEEL
THAT THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL IS QUITE THERE YET THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
I AM SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAMELA MILLER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LAUGH BECAUSE I
TO WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR WE ARE
NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
ARE WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL.
I IN FACT WE AGREE WHOLE
HEARTEDLY WITH THE CONCEPT
THERE'S NO REASON IS WE HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION WITH THE
DRINKING WATER ISSUE.
THERE'S NO REASON THAT ANYONE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD BE LIVING WITH THESE
ISSUES --
AND SO WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON OF THIS BIG
ISSUE.
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF
OF FOR WORKING WITH US OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS THEY HAVE
WORKED WITH US --
ANNA IN ADDRESSING A LOT OF OUR
CONCERNS.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
THEIR EFFORTS.
AND THERE'S STILL A COUPLE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
THOUGH AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THERE MAY BE A
FEW POINTS THAT NEED.
TO BE WORKED OUT JUST A LITTLE
MORE.
AT IN TERMS OF THE ANNEXATION OF
ISSUE AFTER THE EXTENSION OF
SERVICE THERE'S STILL SOME OF
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS ABOUT --
MANDATING AN ANNEXATION --
DEPENDING UPON WHETHER IT'S A A
SPECIAL DISTRICT THAT IS --
DOING THE EXTENSION OF SERVICE
OR A MUNICIPALITY.
AYE AND SO ON THE OPPOSED UP
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON A I AM
LIKE A BIT LITTLE BIT
CLARIFICATION ON THAT THEY
CONCERN US IF THAT ACTUALLY
REMOVES THAT --
ANNEXATION A MANDATE WITH
RESPECT TO THE DISTRICTS.
AND THEN IN ADDITION THE NEW
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN A
RAISE A QUESTION ABOUT. FOR US
JUST HOW FAR THE EXTENSION MAY
OCCUR AND WHAT DOES THAT
ACTUALLY MEAN IN TERMS OF OUR
GROWTH INDUCING SO.
AT AND THEN FINALLY IN TERMS OF
THE ANNEXATION ONCE THE
EXTENSION OF SERVICES ORDERED.
TO ENSURE THAT THAT ANNEXATION
PROCESS GOES THROUGH THE LAUGH
CHO THAT IT IS.
A ONCE THE WATER BOARD MANDATES
THE EXTENSION OF SERVICE.
THEN --
THEREBY MANDATING THE ANNEXATION
THAT THAT PROCESS GO THROUGH
LAUGH CHO.
SO WITH THAT OUT APPRECIATE
AGAIN ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND YOUR STAFF AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION AND WORKING THROUGH
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE VERY ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
SING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS FROM MANY YES
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU OF SENATOR I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON I'M WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE --
ALONG WITH SENATOR MINDING YOUR
COLLEAGUE --
LOUIS ARE WORKING REALLY HARD TO
CLEAN UP THE WATER IN CALIFORNIA
BOTH THE WATER THAT --
THAT THAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH
AND IN THIS BILL IN THE DRINKING
WATER.
ISSUE WE'VE TRIED TO WORK ON IT
THIS YEAR IN THE BUDGET OF THE
GOVERNOR --
WAS AMENABLE TO THAT AND IT JUST --
IT'S ONE OF THE MORE COMPLICATED
ISSUES OUT LITERALLY SO I HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO IT YET BUT
WE WILL GET IT DONE --
THERE'S TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS STILL SITTING OUT THERE
AND WE'RE NOT DONE TALKING ABOUT
THE ISSUE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
SO A LITTLE BIT OF HOPE FOR THIS
YEAR BUT WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT
LEADS US --
I'D OF I DID WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION BECAUSE I'M JUST NOT
QUITE CLEAR HOW HOW WAS I THINGS
WILL WORK UNDER YOUR BILL.
ON AS YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD ON
ISSUES IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS WHERE --
PEOPLE BEEN ASKED TO INSTALL
SEPTIC SYSTEMS AND I AND THE
COSTA BEEN EXORBITANT AND THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO'VE LIVED IN THE
MOUNTAINS FOREVER AND THEY CAN'T
BEAR THOSE COSTS.
THEY CAUSED AN UPROAR A COUPLE
YEARS AGO --
SO MY QUESTION IS --
STEP IN CALABASAS NO YEAR YOU
KNOW TRIED NOT TO YOU KNOW
WANTED A IDENTIFY PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES.
SANTA MONICA MOUNDS WASN'T
ENOUGH FOR YOU [inaudible]
GAINES.
YEAH SO I THOUGHT WHAT I JUST
WANT TO KNOW --
HOW THE ECONOMICS ARE GOING TO
WORK HERE WHAT'S THE ENTITLED
AND WHAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LOOK THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND I
KNOW THE? TEN MILLION DOLLAR
HOUSE NEXT TO THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSES THE SLAPPER BUT IT
REALLY DOESN'T DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE PROPERTY AND ECONOMIC
AMOUNTS MIGHT BE WORTH A HAPPIER
PERSON LOSE THEIR THE PEOPLE.
THAT THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT AT YEAH
WHAT WOULD YOU KNOW THEY MOVE
EARLIER BOUGHT IT WHEN I GOT
WORTH THAT'S RIGHT I GOT TO
COMPLETELY GET THAT I'M STILL
AROUND.
I JUST ALSO WANT TO SAY TO YOU
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS IN THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMITTEES AS DEFINED
[inaudible]
ON HOW TO GET THE MONEY TO FIX
THE PROBLEM RIGHT IT'S A BIG
ISSUE.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA JUST
WRITE A CHECK.
UP RIGHT IT'S THERE'S NOTHING TO
DO BOND ISSUE JACKET BILL THE
RAISE FEES SO WITH THIS CREATIVE
APPROACH THAT SENATOR WHAT DID
AND SENATOR --
GROUP --
LENO DID YEARS AGO THE BUDGET
PLATE.
THERE'S OVER A THOUSAND WATER
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THROUGH CONSOLIDATION OF
SOME OF THOSE WATER DISTRICTS
YOU ACTUALLY GET EFFICIENCIES
THAT RESULT IN.
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE CLEAN
WATER PEOPLE IF YOU LOOK FOR
EXAMPLE THE RICHER WATER BOARDS
SINCE WE PUT OUT S. B. TWELVE OR
FIFTEEN OUR ARMED IN THIS HOLE
IN A POSITION PROCESS I BELIEVE
THE NUMBERS WERE YEAH.
THE BOARD HAS ISSUED TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY INFORMAL
CONSOLIDATIONS LETTERS
INDICATING STATE WATER BOARD TO
TED TO INITIATE CONSOLIDATION
WHICH HAVE LED.
TO MORE THAN FORTY VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATIONS NO JUST
GOVERNMENT THINK YOU'LL BUT
DIFFERENT MORE CREATIVELY
[inaudible]
THEN HELPS WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
THAT CONCEPT AND SIEU BEGIN
APPLIED TO WASTE WATER IN
ADDITION.
TO THE CLEAN WATER SIDE BECAUSE
THE ADVERSE HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
IT IS SOMEWHAT LIMITED THAT
SCOPE AND THE ARGUMENTS THAT
WERE MADE HERE TODAY.
YOU KNOW I MEAN WHAT WHAT THE
STATE WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD PUT IN WHICH I DON'T THINK
WAS ACTIVELY REPRESENTED IN THE
IN THE OPPOSITION IT'S AS IF THE
CAPACITY BEYOND WHAT IS NEEDED
FOR CALLING CONSOLIDATION.
IS PROVIDED THAT THE WORDS YOU
GOT TO DISTRICTS THAT ARE IN
TROUBLE YOU CONSOLIDATE.
AND YOU GET EXTRA WATER THE
STATE ONE SIX TWO WATER
PRESUMABLY TO HELP OTHER
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN NEED
VERSES WHATEVER RIGHT THAT'S THE
CONCEPT IN THE SAME PROBLEM WITH
THE TWO EIGHTEEN IDEA FEES.
WHOLE CONCEPT BEHIND THIS IS NOT
TO CHARGE PEOPLE MONEY BUT TO TO
BE THOUGHTFUL AND CREATIVE AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE REASON WE
CHOSE TO EXTEND THIS TO WASTE
WATERS BECAUSE IT'S REALLY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL SO FAR LITERALLY JUST.
ASKING NEIGHBORS TO TALK TO EACH
OTHER NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW WOULD AFFECT THE
ISSUE IN SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS.
CONSERVANCY I I DON'T KNOW ON
AYE AYE MY SENSE IS THAT IT DOES
LET ME LET ME ARE THERE I WASN'T
I DON'T KNOW I WAS USING THAT AS
AN EXAMPLE OF WHERE THERE --
HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS NOT --
SUGGESTING THAT IT NECESSARILY
IS GOING TO HAVE ANY IMPACT
THERE AT ALL.
JUST BY WAY OF EXAMPLE OKAY GOOD
GOOD GOOD.
OKAY UP ON OTHER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT --
I REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT'S
ABOUT 50% GEOGRAPHICALLY ANYWAY
OF RURAL AND YOUR BILL.
MISTER SENATOR IS SPOT ON FOR US
SO I SUPPORTED ONE WOULD WANT AS
A CO AUTHOR WELL YEAH.
IT WOULD TAKE ALL COMERS WHAT
REALLY SOLD ME ON THIS IS THAT
PROVIDES THAT THE COMPULSORY AND
EXHORTATION OR SERVICE EXTENSION
IS A LAST RESORT.
BANG VIED FOR PUBLIC INPUT SO
YOU GOT ME ON THAT ONE THANK YOU.
YEAH AND FOR THE FOR THE TWO NEW
MEMBERS FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY I JUST WANNA SAY THAT.
THE INSPIRATION PUBLISHED OF
ORIGINALLY CAME FROM THE LAUGH
CHO WE WANTED BECAUSE WAY BACK
IN THAT WAY BACK DAYS WE HAD A
WHAT WAS CALLED THE SPECIAL
REORGANIZATION WE SESSION.
AND WHEN I READ THE LAW BACK
THEN IT WAS SO POORLY DONE
HUNDREDS OF THE I'D PAGE COLORS
BUT FOUR YEARS HERE RIGHT IN THE
WHOLE DAMN THING.
AND AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO INTEGRATE SET
DEALS OF SPHERES OF INFLUENCE
AND HOW YOU HAVE ANNEXATIONS TO
WHAT YOU HEARD HERE TODAY WAS
THEIR CONCERN ABOUT LAUGH COPE
STILL BEING PART OF THAT PROCESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE WHOLE THING
CAME FROM SKULL THE KNOX CORTESE
HERTZBERG LAW.
AND I'D PUT THAT IN THIS ONCE IN
A ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS IF IT --
WAY BACK IN THE WAYBACK MACHINE.
THREE EVER MOTION YEAH.
WORTH BILL OKAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO AND SOME REMEMBER BLOOM
LISTEN.
SECOND TOMORROW SUMMER OF THEIR
DATA --
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL --
FOR FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT BUT WAS REALLY
KEY FOR ME BECAUSE I FIGHT THIS
FIGHT ALL THE TIME ABOUT
DEFINITION.
AND IT --
THANK YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU ANYONE WHO'S LIVED AND THE
COUNTRY THAT'S HOW BAD SEPTIC
TANK I CAN RELATE TO EVERYTHING
THEY SAID.
WE HAD ABOUT SEPTIC TANK AND
THEY'RE NOT CHEAP AND THEIR
PRANK OR A PRETTY FAR COSTLY --
I THINK --
RESEARCHERS AT REACHING
AGREEMENTS.
A HERE TAKING MELISSA HIS --
SALSA BRADBURY BILL THE DAY I
HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION HERE BECAUSE THIS
IS.
YOU KNOW.
THIS IS A HARD ONE I MEAN HOW
YOU GONNA FIX THIS AND SEPTIC
SYSTEM AND WE JUST DID PRIVACY
HOPEFULLY TOMORROW HAPPENS YEAH
SO THAT WE CAN FIGURE IT OUT
YEAH I I WOULD HOPE WE CAN WORK
THIS OUT BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND I I HAD.
WE FELT ABOUT LOAN ARE PROPERLY
FIRST BUT OUR PROPERTY YEARS AGO.
IT WAS EXPENSIVE.
MY DAD STUCK HIS NECK A BUYING A
PIECE OF PROPERTY AND THEN TO
HAVE THAT FAIL AMONG THEM HOW WE
HAD TO LIVE WITH THAT FOR AWHILE
WITH A COUPLE OF OUT HOUSES WAS
NOT REAL PLEASANT EVERYONE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT EVERYBODY'S
GOING THROUGH IT DAY IN AND DAY
OUT SO.
I'M WITH THAT --
I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
AS I TO CLOSE.
ASSESSMENT YOU THINK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SECRETARY.
WELL THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
ORDER REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY
HIGH AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE COVEY AERO.
COVEY COVEY HERO I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OKAY WE NEED TO DO SOME ADD ONS.
YOUR DESCENDANTS ON ON LET.
YEAH I REALLY THINK.
YEAH WE ACTUALLY HAVE WITH THEM
NOTION.
OKAY BUT BUT I WAS RAISED BY.
ITEM NUMBER WHEN SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIX FIVE WIENER MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO A PROBES.
RUBIO AYE AYE RUBIO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT WIENER.
MOTIONS TO PASS IS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE [inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] FOR SEND
OUT TEN EIGHTEEN ALAN MOTIONS TO
PASS GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I ITEM [inaudible]
THAT PASSED.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATE BILL
TWELVE SIXTY JACKSON MOTION AS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE. TWELVE
SIXTY JACKSON [inaudible]
NO I GALLAGHER I ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN MCGUIRE MOTION IS TO
PASS [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
I HAVE.
GALLAGHER NO RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
I NUMBER NUMBER EIGHT IS OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATE BILL
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN NINETY EIGHT GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER R. AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE [inaudible] TO REAP
[inaudible]
MAYBE WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SERGEANT.
YEAH HE'S.
THERE.
I AM NEVER FORCE ANNABELLE TEN
EIGHTEEN ALAN.
GALLAGHER I TEND NOT VOTING.
I HAD THE YEAH.
AGAIN THANK ASSEMBLY RIPARIAN.
NOT AS GOOD [inaudible]
THERE IS.
THE GREAT PROBLEM [inaudible]
ELECTED.
OKAY I GOT UP THERE OR ASSEMBLY
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT WINNER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED IN
RE REFER TO THE CUP.
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WALDRON.
NO WALDRON NO [inaudible]
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN MCGUIRE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WALDRON
[inaudible]
I'M SAYING.
MY WALDRON NO
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SHE HAD A
ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN
HERTZBERG IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON NO.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED